LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON THIS JULY
3RD, 2024. LET'S GET OUR
BUSINESS STARTED IN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WHEN I SAY GOOD MORNING
TO MADAM SECRETARY. MAGUIRE HERE.
MAGUIRE HERE. GROVE. EGGMAN
EGGMAN! HERE! JONES! I'M HERE!
JONES HERE. LAIRD. LAIRD, HERE.
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
SECRETARY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
WHO ARE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM AND WATCHING ONLINE. WE ARE
NEAR THE DEADLINE FOR POLICY.
AND THAT MEANS EACH ONE OF THESE
HARD WORKING SENATORS ARE GOING
TO BE IN AND OUT OF COMMITTEE.
NONE OF THEM EVEN MEAN ANY
DISRESPECT. BUT JUST KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SIX COMMITTEES
HAPPENING ALL AT ONCE. ALL START
AT 9:00 AND SO WILL BE IN AND
OUT TODAY. AND WE DO SEND
SINCERE APOLOGIES. AND THAT WILL
ALSO INCLUDE MYSELF, WE ALSO
WILL HAVE OUR VICE CHAIR WHO
WILL BE HERE IN JUST A FEW
MOMENTS. WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO DO, AS IS TYPICAL HERE
AT SENATE RULES COMMITTEE, IS
TAKE UP SOME ADMINISTRATIVE
ITEMS, THEN WE'LL START OUT WITH
MISS LESLIE. WE'RE GOING TO ASK
MISS LESLIE TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD, AND WE'LL GET LESLIE
RIGHT TO YOU AND APOLOGIZE ABOUT
THE DELAY. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
CARE OF SOME HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS,
AND WE'LL COME RIGHT BACK OVER
TO YOU TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
FORMAL INTRODUCTION. SO, LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN, COMMITTEE, WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO START OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE PART OF TODAY'S
HEARING UNDER BILL REFERRALS,
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TAKE UP
ITEM TWO REFERENCE OF BILLS TO
COMMITTEES. IS THERE A MOTION
FOR APPROVAL? WE REFER THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT IS A
MOTION BY SENATOR LAIRD. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MCGUIRE I MCGUIRE. AYE.
GROVE EGGMAN. EGGMAN I JONES I
JONES I LAIRD I LAIRD I ON CALL
4 TO 0. THAT'S A40 VOTE. THAT
ITEM IS GOING TO REMAIN ON CALL.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. COMMITTEE.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE GOING ON
TO FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS. THESE
ARE ITEMS THREE THROUGH SIX.
ITEMS THREE THROUGH SIX. MR.
CHAIR, I WOULD MOVE ITEMS THREE
THROUGH SIX. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT IS A MOTION BY MR. LAIRD.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MCGUIRE I MCGUIRE.
AYE. GROVE EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
JONES. JONES I LAIRD. LAIRD I
FOR ZERO. UNCLE FOUR ZERO VOTE.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THAT ON
CALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH TO THE
COMMITTEE. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO MADAM BOARD
MEMBER. MADAM BOARD MEMBERS.
WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU, MISS
LESLIE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN UP OUR APPOINTEE
PRESENTATIONS. MISS LESLIE IS
ADVANCING FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AS A BOARD MEMBER FROM
THE INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR
GOVERNING BOARD. AND IT IS HOT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO ANTICIPATE
YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE US AN
UPDATE HERE TODAY. SO WE'RE
GOING TO KNOCK ON WOOD LIGHTS.
STAY ON, SO LONG STORY SHORT, WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR HARD WORK.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. MADAM
BOARD MEMBER, WE'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH TWO MINUTES FOR
OPENING TESTIMONY. IF THERE ARE
ANY INDIVIDUALS HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO ACKNOWLEDGE OR
WATCHING ONLINE, WE DO INVITE
YOU TO DO SO. I'LL GIVE YOU A
32ND WARNING WHEN YOU GET CLOSE
TO THAT TWO MINUTES, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. AND AGAIN, WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN
BOYD. YES, YOU'RE DOING GOOD.
WE'RE TURNING UP HIS MIC JUST A
BIT. GOOD MORNING. GOOD, CHAIR
MCGUIRE, CDVA, VICE CHAIR. GROVE
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU ALL THIS MORNING.
IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE
TODAY, TO BE CONSIDERED FOR A
THREE YEAR TERM TO THE CAISO
BOARD, FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DO
NOT KNOW ME, WHICH, FORTUNATELY,
I AM MEETING YOU FOR THE FIRST
TIME. I'M A FOURTH GENERATION
CALIFORNIAN. I WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN THE BAY AREA. I MY
FAMILY COMES FROM THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY, FRESNO AND KERN
AREA. I'VE LIVED FOR THE LAST 20
YEARS DOWN IN LOS ANGELES, WHERE
I MET MY HUSBAND, ALAN, AND
RAISED MY TWO SONS, JACOB AND
MICHAEL, AND UNFORTUNATELY, THEY
WILL NOT BE HERE TODAY BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THEY ARE WORKING, BUT
THEY MAY BE LISTENING IN. I HOPE,
AS IS MY MOTHER, JOAN LESLIE IN
THE BAY AREA AND THE PGA
TERRITORY. AS A MATTER OF FACT,
AWAITING HER. NO COMMENT. YEAH.
NO COMMENT. OKAY,
PROFESSIONALLY, I HAVE WORKED
FOR THE LAST 30 YEARS IN LOCAL,
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
BUSINESS. I BEGAN MY CAREER HERE
IN SACRAMENTO WITH THIS IS GOING
TO DATE ME, EXCEPT FOR SENATOR
LAIRD'S GOING TO UNDERSTAND FOR
LEO MCCARTHY, WHO WAS MY FIRST
BOSS FOR TEN YEARS, HE WAS THE
FORMER SPEAKER AND THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR. HE WAS A
GREAT GUY. HE WAS MY MENTOR AND
MY FRIEND FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
I LEARNED EARLY ON THAT THE
IMPORTANCE OF PUBLIC, PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS AND ACHIEVE ARE
CRITICAL FOR US ACHIEVING OUR
GOALS, AND I LEAD A BUSINESS
GROUP DOWN IN LOS ANGELES CALLED
THE LOS ANGELES BUSINESS
COUNCIL. I WORKED HARD AND AM
COMMITTED TO RELIABILITY AND
EFFECTIVE AND COST EFFECTIVE
DECARBONIZATION OF THE WORLD'S
FOURTH LARGEST ECONOMY, FOURTH
OR FIFTH, DEPENDING ON THE DAY.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND AT THE
CAISO. WE DO THIS BY PLANNING
ROBUST TRANSMISSION. WE OPERATE
AN EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
ENERGY MARKET, WHICH IS GREATLY
EXPANDING AS YOU KNOW, AND WE'VE
WE'VE INTEGRATED HIGH LEVELS OF
CLEAN ENERGY. WE'RE WE'RE UP TO
ABOUT SIX GIGAWATTS A YEAR. WE
HAVE TO GET TO SEVEN AND STAY
THERE FOR TEN YEARS, RIGHT? TO
GET TO OUR OUR SB 100 GOALS AND
WE'VE DONE THIS IN A DEPENDABLE
AND EFFECTIVE WAY, HOPEFULLY A
LOW COST WAY TO CALIFORNIA'S OR
THE LOWEST COST. AND WE CONTINUE
TO ENHANCE THE GRID WITH WITH
EFFECTIVE NEW MARKETS LIKE THE
ENERGY IMBALANCE MARKET, THE AIM
THAT MARKET IS IN 22, BALANCING
AUTHORITIES. AND AS YOU KNOW, WE
GOT FERC PERMISSION AND VOTED TO
CREATE THE Â DAM, WHICH IS THE
DAY AHEAD MARKET. THIS WILL
ALLOW US TO CREATE GREATER
MARKET PARTICIPATION IN THE
WEST. SO I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS TODAY, AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. MADAM BOARD
MEMBER, WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN IT UP. WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU AND I APOLOGIZE. I
HAVE TO THE MINUTE I'M DONE
ASKING YOU QUESTIONS, GO PRESENT
A BILL IN LABOR AND PARTICIPATE
IN A DEBATE. THERE AND I WILL BE
BACK TO VOTE AND TRY TO BE BACK
FOR THE OTHERS. ALTHOUGH I CAN
SEE MR. RECHTSHAFFEN WITH A SIGH
OF RELIEF RIGHT NOW, SO LET ME
ASK A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS TO
KICK IT OFF. AND ONE IS TO TEE
OFF OF WHAT YOU SAID. OBVIOUSLY
RENEWABLES AND THE GRID AND GRID
MANAGEMENT IS A BIG DEAL, ON
STORAGE, HOW DO WE CONNECT MORE
STORAGE TO THE GRID OR HOW DOES
CAL ISO HELP IN PARTNERSHIP TO
FACILITATE THAT? BECAUSE IT
MAKES A BIG DEAL IN ALLOWING OUR
RENEWABLES TO WORK WELL. PART OF
THE REASON, YOU KNOW, TODAY IS
LOOKING LIKE MAYBE A 45,000
MEGAWATT DAY, WE THINK THAT WILL
BE OUR PEAK TODAY, EVEN WITH
THIS EXTREME HEAT, AND THAT WE
HAVE A BUFFER OF AT LEAST 3000MW
BEFORE WE WOULD HAVE TO USE ANY
ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS LIKE FLEX
ALERTS AND OTHER THINGS. AND
PART OF THE REASON WE'RE IN SUCH
GOOD SHAPE AT THE MOMENT IS WE
HAD TWO COOL YEARS, RIGHT, OF
WEATHER, WHICH WAS A BLESSING
AND A LOT OF RAIN. BUT BASICALLY
IT'S BECAUSE WE, YOU KNOW, THE
CPUC THROUGH THE RA PLANNING
PROCESS, ALLOWED US TO,
LITERALLY PUT ALMOST EIGHT
GIGAWATTS OF BATTERY STORAGE
ONTO THE GRID AND WILL BE AT
ABOUT TEN, GIGAWATTS BY THE END
OF THIS YEAR. SO THAT'S REALLY
THE BUFFER THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
PEAK OF, OF, OF, OF OUR ENERGY
USE, THE NECK OF THE DUCK, SO TO
SPEAK, THAT THAT BATTERY STORAGE
HELPS US, WITH, WITH THAT WITH,
WITH THE, THE PEAK POWER, WHEN
OUR SOLAR GOES OFF, WE HAVE THE
BATTERY STORAGE. SO BATTERY
STORAGE IS CRITICAL TO
RELIABILITY. AND I'M JUST
UNDERSTANDING BECAUSE WE HAVE
PROBLEMS IN SORT OF CONNECTING
THINGS TO THE GRID, HOW YOU ARE
A PARTNER AND SORT OF TRYING TO
ADDRESS THAT OR EASE THAT. WELL,
I THINK WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
WITH INTERCONNECTING THE 8000MW
OF BATTERY STORAGE AND, I THINK
THAT'S OUR JOB TO INTERCONNECT
IT. RIGHT, AND PLAN FOR IT. AND
THEN WE DEPEND ON THE LSCS TO
ACTUALLY DO IT RIGHT. AND SO WE
SUCCESSFULLY HAVE DONE IT. I'M
NOT SURE IF I'M ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTION. WELL, I THINK THAT
THAT OUR CHALLENGE IS MEETING
OUR GOALS. IT IS ABOUT GETTING
THINGS UP AND GETTING THEM ON
THE GRID. WE HAVE THE CHALLENGE
OF EXPEDITING THAT AND DEALING
WITH THAT. BUT YOU HAVE SORT OF
SOME RESPONSIBILITIES IN
RELATION TO THE GRID THAT REALLY
ARE GOING TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE OR
HELP FACILITATE THAT. I'M
LOOKING FOR HOW YOU VIEW THAT.
SO SINCE AUGUST 2020, WHEN WE
HAD THE LOAD SHED, I THINK IT
ENHANCED THE COOPERATION GREATLY
BETWEEN THE CPUC, THE CEC AND
THE CAISO. AND WHAT HAPPENED IS
THE AMOUNT OF PLANNING WE HAVE
DONE WITH THE CPUC, IRP. YOU
KNOW, WE'VE IDENTIFIED EXACTLY
WHERE, YOU KNOW, POWER SHOULD GO
AND WHERE WE CAN DO IT AT THE
LOWEST COST IN TERMS OF
TRANSMISSION UPGRADES. AND SO
BATTERIES AREN'T RANDOMLY PUT ON
THE GRID. THEY'RE THEY'RE
ACTUALLY PART OF A PLANNING
PROCESS THAT SHOWS US WHERE THEY
SHOULD GO IN ORDER TO OFFSET,
YOU KNOW, ENERGY NEEDS,
PARTICULARLY IN URBAN AREAS
WHERE THERE'S HIGH ENERGY USE.
SO THIS IS A HIGHLY COORDINATED,
AND FORECASTED I GET THAT. AND
YOU SEE, I'M VERY LUCKY BECAUSE
IN MY DISTRICT, SOME OF THE
BIGGEST THINGS TRANSMISSION
EXISTS. IF NGUYEN COMES ON THE
TRANSMISSION IS AT DIABLO. IF
STORAGE COMES ON IN MORRO BAY,
THERE'S LEFTOVER FOSSIL FUEL
STORAGE, ALL THE STORAGE THAT
HAS COME ON IN MOSS LANDING
CONNECTS TO THE TRANSMISSION
FROM THE FORMAL FOSSIL FUEL, NOT
SOME OF THE OTHER DISTRICTS ARE
AS LUCKY. I MEAN, SENATOR
MCGUIRE'S THE WIND UP THERE IS
IN A TRANSMISSION DESERT, AND SO
HOW DO YOU HELP FACILITATE SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT THAT ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE? WELL, BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LOT OF WAYS TO ACQUIRE
ENERGY THAT ISN'T BEING
GENERATED IN HIS DISTRICT.
RIGHT. SO OUR ENERGY IMBALANCE
MARKET, FOR INSTANCE, WE'RE
BRINGING POWER IN FROM DIFFERENT
PLACES IN THE WEST, HYDRO FROM
THE NORTHWEST. AND I BELIEVE
SENATOR MCGUIRE IS GOING TO BE
IN VERY GOOD SHAPE. WE JUST
OKAYED $6 BILLION WORTH OF NEW
TRANSMISSION, OF WHICH, YOU
KNOW, A THIRD OF THAT IS WHEN
OFFSHORE. RIGHT. SO WE'RE
PLANNING FOR AT LEAST FOUR
GIGAWATTS. AT HUMBOLDT AND, AND
MONTEREY. RIGHT. SO MORRO BAY
DON'T FREAK OUT THE PEOPLE.
OKAY. I'M SO SORRY. MORRO BAY. I
WILL NEVER SAY MONTEREY EVER
AGAIN. I'M TEASING BAY. OKAY.
YEAH WELL, AND THEN, AND I
COULDN'T HELP BUT RESIST. YOU'RE
SO EXCITED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
IT RAINED FOR TWO YEARS. I AM
ONE PERSON'S RAIN. IT'S ANOTHER
PERSON'S LEVEE BREAKING, HIGHWAY
FALLING IN THE OCEAN. WHARF'S
GOING DOWN. SO, THE OTHER THING
IS YOU TEED UP THE QUESTION. IN
YOUR OPENING ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN TODAY TO DEMAND
MANAGEMENT. AND TRADITIONALLY,
THEIR SKEPTICISM ABOUT DEMAND
MANAGEMENT. BUT ON THAT Kò DAY
IN SEPTEMBER OF 2022, WITHOUT
CONSULTING CAL ISO, THE GOVERNOR
SENT OUT A MASS EMAIL BLAST AND
EVERYBODY AT CAL ISO THIS CAN'T
BE RIGHT. THE DEMAND IS DROPPING
AND I THINK YOU CAN ONLY DO THAT
ONCE OR TWICE A YEAR AND HAVE IT
WORK. BUT WHAT DID THAT INFORM
YOUR VIEW ABOUT DEMAND
MANAGEMENT? WELL, I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN A FAN OF DEMAND MANAGEMENT,
BUT THAT'S BECAUSE I COME FROM
LOS ANGELES AND I SERVED ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER
BOARD FOR MANY YEARS. SO I'VE
SEEN WHAT DEMAND MANAGEMENT CAN
DO. YEAH, IT'S A POWERFUL IT'S A
POWERFUL TOOL. THE CHALLENGE
WITH IT IS, IS THE DEPENDABILITY
OF PEOPLE POWERING DOWN BECAUSE
THAT'S VOLUNTARY RIGHT. IT'S NOT
WE DON'T IT'S NOT A MANDATORY
DEAL. BUT BUT I THINK IN IN
UTILITIES WHERE PEOPLE HAVE HAD
EXPERIENCE WITH DEMAND
MANAGEMENT, IT WORKS REALLY
EFFECTIVELY. OKAY. WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT. I'D LOVE TO
TALK MORE, BUT I HAVE TO GO TO
THE LABOR COMMITTEE AND I WILL
BE BACK TO VOTE. AND I
APPRECIATE YOU. I'M ONE OF THE
FEW, MAYBE SENATOR GROVE, WE
WERE HERE FOR YOUR LAST
CONFIRMATION AND HAD AN ANIMATED
DISCUSSION THAT SATISFIED ME
ALONG WITH YOUR SERVICE. SO
THANK YOU FOR BEING WILLING TO
DO ANOTHER TERM. THANK YOU.
THANKS, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR. SENATOR, PLEASE, MADAM
VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MY APOLOGIES FOR BEING
TARDY, GOOD TO SEE YOU, MISS
LESLIE, I, I THINK YOU'VE DONE
AN INCREDIBLE JOB FROM THE LAST
TIME THAT WE SAW YOU. AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR, NOT ONLY YOUR
KNOWLEDGE, BUT YOUR ABILITY TO
CONVEY YOUR KNOWLEDGE AND MAKE
SURE THAT THAT JUST STUFF GETS
DONE. I DO HAVE A QUESTION.
BECAUSE SOMETHING NEW CAME UP.
SINCE THE LAST TIME WE'VE HAD A
CONFIRMATION, IN DOWN IN OTAY
MESA, IT TOOK 17 DAYS TO PUT OUT
A LITHIUM BATTERY FIRE, AND
EVACUATED A LOCAL AREA, MOSTLY
LOW SOCIO ECONOMIC,
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY AREA
WHERE THIS BATTERY STATION IS,
IS AT, IT RELEASED HIGHLY TOXIC
FUMES INTO THE AREA. HYDROGEN
FLUORIDE BEING ONE OF THEM.
WHERE, THE DEFINITION OF A
DANGER TO LIFE AND HEALTH IS 30
PARTS PER MILLION. AND THIS FIRE
OVER 17 DAYS RELEASED ABOUT 600
PARTS PER MILLION INTO THE AIR,
HOW ARE YOU COORDINATING WITH
COORDINATING WITH THE CPUC AND
THE CEC TO ENSURE THAT ADEQUATE
BATTERY STORAGE IS SAFE, IT'S
DOWN THERE IN BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES. AND, THAT WAS A
DISASTER. AND THEY CAN'T EVEN
PUT THE FIRE OUT. THEY JUST HAVE
TO WAIT FOR IT TO CONTINUE TO
BURN. SO CAN YOU EXPAND ON THAT
AND WHAT YOUR PLAN IS? WELL, YOU
KNOW, THE GROWTH OF BATTERIES
STORAGE HAS BEEN EXPONENTIAL IN
A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME. AND
I'M NOT SURE THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING FIRE CODES HAVE KEPT
UP. AND I KNOW THAT YOU'VE HAD
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE MEETINGS
ABOUT IT, ABOUT UPDATING THE
FIRE CODE, I THINK ALSO THE
TECHNOLOGIES OF BATTERIES ARE
QUITE DIFFERENT. YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE THE LITHIUM FOR OUR
BATTERY, WHICH WE'VE BEEN
DEPENDING ON. BUT QUITE FRANKLY,
FLOW BATTERIES ARE BECOMING
COMMONPLACE. AND IN A FLOW
BATTERY YOU YOU DON'T HAVE THE
CONCENTRATION OF ENERGY WHERE
THE BATTERIES HEAT LIKE THAT.
THEY FLOW THROUGH THE LITERALLY
THEY FLOW THROUGH. RIGHT. IF
THEY'RE NOT, YOU'RE NOT. THIS IS
GOING TO SOUND REALLY TECHNICAL.
YOU'RE NOT SHOVING POWER INTO A
BATTERY. OKAY. AND THEN IT'S
SITTING THERE AND IT'S HEATING
UP. RIGHT. INSTEAD THERE'S A
THERE'S A FLOW THROUGH OF THE
ENERGY. SO THERE'S NO HEAT
GETTING CONCENTRATED IN ONE
PLACE. SO I THINK THE TECHNOLOGY
OF BATTERIES IS IMPROVING NOW.
AND THAT, THAT THE CODE NEEDS TO
CATCH UP BECAUSE THAT'S A SAFETY
ISSUE. RIGHT. THAT'S, THAT'S A
FIRE AND SAFETY ISSUE. THE
MANAGING OF THE BATTERIES.
THAT'S THAT'S FORTUNATELY OR
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T REGULATE
THAT AT THE CHI. SO THAT'S NOT
EXACTLY OUR SWIM LANE, BUT WE'RE
VERY AWARE OF IT. AND YOU'RE
RIGHT TO BRING IT UP BECAUSE THE
SAFETY OF BATTERIES,
PARTICULARLY GIVEN OUR RELIANCE
ON THEM AT THE MOMENT AND THE
TOOL THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING US
AND MANAGING A RELIABLE GRID IS,
IS QUITE IMPORTANT. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. THANK
YOU, HAVE YOU EVER HEARD OF
GEOLOGICAL THERMAL ENERGY
STORAGE? NO. I'D LIKE TO SEND
YOU SOME INFORMATION ON IT.
CALIFORNIA IS DOING WHAT THEY
CALL A TRANSITION OFF OF,
DOMESTIC FUEL, AND GETTING
IMPORTED FUEL FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES. BUT NEVERTHELESS,
WE'RE NOT GETTING PERMITS, BUT
THEY'RE USING TECHNOLOGY IN MY
DISTRICT TO CAPTURE THE WATER
UNDERGROUND IN THE OIL CAVERNS,
LIKE THE WATER. AND IT'S STEAM
GENERATED HEATS UP, AND THEY'VE
ACTUALLY DEMONSTRATED IT CAN
HOLD BATTERY STORAGE FOR 400
DAYS. SO I'D JUST LIKE TO SEND
YOU SOME INFORMATION. I THINK IT
MIGHT SOMETHING I KNOW NEW
TECHNOLOGIES, WIND, OFFSHORE
WIND, EVERYTHING IS COMING
ONLINE VERY, VERY FAST. AND I
JUST THINK INSTEAD OF, YOU KNOW,
I DON'T WANT TO SAY TRANSITION
FROM LITHIUM BATTERIES TO THIS,
BUT I'M JUST SAYING THERE'S GOT
TO BE BETTER TECHNOLOGY OUT
THERE INSTEAD OF JUST LETTING
LITHIUM BURN FOR DAYS. AND THIS
IS ALL UNDERGROUND AND IT'S USED
WITH WATER, SO IT'S HYDRO, I'D
LIKE TO SEND YOU SOME
INFORMATION. I THINK YOU'RE
EXCEPTIONAL AT WHAT YOU DO. I'M
GLAD YOU'RE WILLING TO TAKE ON
THE, THIS OPPORTUNITY THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS GIVING YOU FOR
ANOTHER TERM, I REMEMBER
VISITING CAL ISO, AND IT WAS ALL
THE COMPUTER SCREENS AND
EVERYTHING THAT YOU HAVE TO
TRACK TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
CALIFORNIANS FLIP THAT SWITCH,
THE LIGHTS COME ON. SO THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. AND LET ME
ASK THOSE QUESTIONS AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SEND YOU
THIS INFORMATION. I APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MADAM VICE CHAIR. WE'RE
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR
EGGMAN. GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. YOU'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT ENERGY. I LIKE
THAT, CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT, AS WE CONTINUE TO
DIVERSIFY THE GRID, THE
REGIONALIZATION OF THE GRID AND
THE POTENTIAL, LIKE, EVEN A
NATIONAL GRID? CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT THAT? AND THE DIFFICULTIES
WITH THAT OR OR POTENTIALS?
WELL, OKAY. SO THE QUESTION IS
BOTH, WHAT DO I THINK ABOUT A
REGIONAL GRID? A REGIONAL GRID,
A NATIONAL GRID, CORRECT. AS, AS
WE LOOK AT THE COMPLICATION OF
REGIONALIZATION, HOW MUCH IS
THAT COMPOUNDED GOING NATIONAL?
I LIKE THAT QUESTION BECAUSE
THAT'S THAT'S A BIG THINKING.
OKAY. WE JUST CAME FROM THE ERC
BACK IN WASHINGTON IN MAY.
THAT'S WHERE ALL THE ISO GRID
ISOS MEET AND CONVENE. AND WE
MET WITH THE FERC COMMISSIONERS,
THREE OF THEM, AND THE GOOD NEWS
IS WE ARE CONSIDERED LEADERS IN
THE COUNTRY AT THIS POINT,
PARTICULARLY ON OUR QUÊ
MANAGEMENT AND THE FERC 2023
ORDER. THE REASON I SAY THIS IS,
AS YOU KNOW, FERC DOES REGULATE
US, DOES MANAGE US, AND WE HAVE
TO ADHERE TO A TARIFF IN ORDER
TO DO BUSINESS. SO WITHIN THE
TARIFF IS WHAT WE'RE ALLOWED TO
DO. SO I LIKE TO START WITH
REGIONAL FIRST BECAUSE BECAUSE
EVEN THAT'S A STRETCH FOR, YOU
KNOW, FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE TO GET
THEIR HEAD AROUND. RIGHT.
BECAUSE BECAUSE WE FORM THE ISO
TO MANAGE OUR VÀ. RIGHT. OUR,
AND WHAT HAPPENED WAS, IS, IS
THAT AS WE CREATED THESE LAWS TO
INTEGRATE HIGH LEVELS OF CLEAN
ENERGY, WE'RE MUCH BETTER OFF
BEING IN A REGIONAL PARTNERSHIP.
AND WHAT WE LEARNED FROM THE,
EHM, THE ENERGY IMBALANCE MARKET
THAT BEGAN YOU KNOW, NOW ALMOST
6 OR 7 YEARS AGO, AS WE'VE SAVED
$5.5 BILLION BY BY MOVING POWER
ABOUT 5% OF OUR REAL TIME POWER
OVER 22 DAYS. SO WHAT HAPPENS IS
THE GEOGRAPHIC DIFFERENCES START
TO BE A PLUS, BECAUSE WHEN OUR
SOLAR GOES DOWN, THERE'S STILL
WIND BLOWING, YOU KNOW, IN IN
THE WEST AND VICE VERSA. AND
WHEN WE'VE GOTTEN IN TROUBLE,
LIKE BACK IN 2020, THE NORTHWEST
HYDRO CAME AND HELPED US. RIGHT.
AND OTHER PARTS OF, OF THE WEST.
AND THEN WHEN, WHEN THE WEST AND
THE SOUTHWEST WERE IN TROUBLE
THE LAST TWO YEARS. AND I'M VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE RAIN BECAUSE
WE STAYED COOL AND WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE SAME LOAD DEMANDS, WE
WERE ABLE TO EXPORT POWER. SO
THIS IMPORTING AND EXPORTING OF
POWER ON A WESTERN GRID IS
CRITICAL TO OUR ABILITY TO ADD
120GW OF NEW POWER TO THIS
SYSTEM, WHICH IS CURRENTLY A 50
GIGAWATT SYSTEM. RIGHT. THIS IS
THREE TIMES ALMOST THREE TIMES
BIGGER, RIGHT? SO I WOULD SAY
THE WESTERN HAVING A WESTERN
ENERGY MARKET IS CRITICAL TO OUR
SUCCESS. AND THAT'S WHY WE MOVED
AHEAD WITH THE DAY AHEAD MARKET.
SO INSTEAD OF JUST TRADING REAL
TIME, WE'RE NOW GOING TO TRADE A
DAY AHEAD. AND WE COULD BE
TRADING UPWARDS OF 80% OF OUR
POWER IN THE WEST. OKAY 80% OF
THE POWER IN THE WEST. THAT'S A
LOT OF POWER MOVING RIGHT NOW.
PEOPLE HAVE TO OPT IN TO THAT.
THAT'S A VOLUNTARY SYSTEM.
RIGHT. BUT I'M REALLY HAPPY TO
SAY THAT, YOU KNOW, PACIFIC
CORPS IN NEVADA COMMITTED AND IS
NOW, YOU KNOW, WORKING WITH US
FOR THE EDM THAT WOULD LAUNCH IN
2026. AND ALSO PORTLAND, JUST
JUST SIGNED. AND WE HAVE
COMMITMENTS RIGHT NOW AND I'M
VERY HAPPY TO SAY THIS FROM BOTH
SMUD AND BANK AND DWP. SO I
THINK IT WAS CRITICAL THAT
CALIFORNIA UTILITIES WANT TO BE
PART OF THE EDM. IT TELLS YOU
THEY GREATLY BENEFIT. OF THAT
5.5 BILLION WE GOT, YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA BENEFITED ABOUT A
THIRD OF THAT. YOU KNOW SO
THAT'S SO INSTEAD OF CURTAILING
SOLAR AND BASICALLY DUMPING IT,
WE WERE ABLE TO SELL IT INTO A
MARKET. OKAY. MUCH BETTER. WE
WERE ALSO ABLE TO BUY POWER
RIGHT AT A REASONABLE COST AS
WELL. SO THE REGIONAL MARKET,
THE AIM WAS CRITICAL TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT WE COULD DO IT
RIGHT IN A COST EFFECTIVE WAY.
AND WE DID IT THROUGH A JOINT
GOVERNING, I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE AWARE OF THAT. THE CAISO
WE HAVE A PARALLEL NGUYEN BOARD,
AND ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO, THE
MARKET DESIGN FOR THE AIM. WE
SHARED JOINT RESPONSIBILITY FOR
BECAUSE IN FAIRNESS TO THESE
OTHER STATES, AS MUCH AS THEY
LOVE THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT
AND THE SENATE CONFIRMATION OUT
OF CALIFORNIA, YOU KNOW, I'M NOT
SURE THEY LOVE THE IDEA OF US
GOVERNING 80% OF THEIR MARKET.
OKAY, SO THAT'S THE ENERGY
MARKET. NOT NOT AN RTO, BUT A
GOVERNING ORGANIZATION OF AN
ENERGY MARKET. SO I WOULD SAY SO
FAR THAT'S THE THAT'S THE PATH.
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE PATH WE'RE
ON. THAT WAY WE CAN HAVE MORE
ASSURANCE THAT THE ENERGY IS
CLEAN. YES. AND SENATOR, I MEAN,
WE YOU KNOW, WE DON'T FERC RIGHT
NOW, I LOVE THE BALANCE OF FERC.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT FERC AND WHO
WOULD SERVE AS FERC MEMBERS. BUT
WHAT I'VE LEARNED OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS IS THAT'S ONE OF
THE LEAST POLITICIZED GROUP.
THEY HAVE TO KEEP A BALANCE OF
DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICANS AT ALL
TIME, NO MATTER WHO'S
APPOINTING. SO IT KEEPS IT MEANS
YOU CAN'T STACK A FERC BOARD.
OKAY. AND I THINK THAT'S RIGHT,
BECAUSE THIS IS SERIOUS, SERIOUS
ENERGY MANAGEMENT OKAY. IT
SHOULD NOT BE POLITICIZED, OKAY.
IT SHOULD BE YOU KNOW, IT SHOULD
BE MAXIMIZE AND OPTIMIZE TO THE
BEST. USE A NATIONAL GRID. YOU
KNOW, THIS THIS IS SOMETHING DOE
TALKS ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY. WE'RE YOU KNOW, WE
CREATED A NEW CTO. YOU KNOW,
THIS. IT'S A NEW SUPPORTING
PARTNERING TRANSMISSION OWNER.
WE'RE BRINGING IN SANDIA. WE
GREENLIGHTED TRANS WEST AND SUN
ZIA. THIS IS A GOOD STRATEGY TO
SAVE MONEY ON TRANSMISSION COSTS
BECAUSE BASICALLY TRANSMISSION
GETS PLANNED IN OTHER STATES AND
IT GETS BUILT AND IT GETS BUILT
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH WITH
MERCHANT PRIVATE ENTITIES, WHICH
MEANS WE'RE NOT PAYING FOR IT.
WE ONLY START PAYING ONCE IT
HITS THE CALIFORNIA LINE. SO
THIS IS A GREAT WAY TO SAVE
MONEY. YEAH, SURE. GO AHEAD.
BUILD OUT YOUR SYSTEMS. NOW, THE
BEST EXAMPLE OF THAT IS THE
WESTERN SPIRIT LINE COMING OUT
IN NEW MEXICO RIGHT NOW. WE'VE
GOT ABOUT 1.3GW OF POWER COMING
OUT OF NEW MEXICO INTO
CALIFORNIA. PRETTY MUCH OUR CARS
AND OUR MUNI'S OFFLOADED THAT A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO, BUT THAT'S
A REAL HIGH RISK DEAL, RIGHT,
BECAUSE THE PRIVATE SECTOR HAD
TO DO THAT. THAT'S WHAT I WAS
SAYING ABOUT PUBLIC. PRIVATE IS
THIS IS NOT GOING TO GET BUILT
ON THE BACK OF ALL GOVERNMENT.
OKAY. THIS IS WE'RE DEFINITELY
IN AN ENHANCED PARTNERSHIP, SO
THE PRIVATE SECTOR HAS TO FEEL
LIKE THEY'VE GOT THEY CAN SEE A
PATHWAY THEMSELVES. RIGHT. TO
TAKE THAT RISK. SO, SO IN TERMS
OF A NATIONAL GRID, I THINK
YOU'RE SEEING YOUR IT'S BEING
ALLOWED FOR FERC CAISO DOE.
THEY'RE ALLOWING FOR THESE
INNOVATIVE NEW WAYS OF DOING
BUSINESS THAT I THINK THAT ARE
HELPING US. SO THAT'S THE
CLOSEST TO SORT OF NATIONALIZING
A GRID IS ALLOWING THESE SORT OF
PRIVATE EFFORTS. DOES THAT.
YEAH. NO. AND IT SOUNDS
PROMISING. AND WHEN AND WHEN
WE'RE MANAGING ALL OF THESE
THINGS COMING IN, AND I MUST
HAVE BEEN BORED LAST NIGHT
BECAUSE I WATCHED TOO MUCH OF
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON AI
BILLS. HOW MANY? YEAH HOW DO IN
ALL OF THESE PREDICTIVE MODELS
ABOUT WHEN THINGS ARE COMING ON
AND OFF, HOW MUCH AI ARE WE
USING AND HOW RIGOROUSLY IS IT
TESTED? YOU KNOW, THAT QUESTION
CAME UP WITH SENATE STAFF A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO, AND THAT'S
A QUESTION I'VE ALSO BEEN
MONITORING AND READING. SO I
READ UP ABOUT HOW WE HANDLE
THAT. OKAY. SO IT TURNS OUT THE
CEC DOES A BASIC FORECAST OF
WHAT OUR NEEDS ARE, RIGHT. AND
THAT'S THEY GO BACK TO THE LSCS,
RIGHT. THE LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES, THEY ASK THEM AND A
LOT OF THAT'S DONE BASED ON
HISTORY. RIGHT AND THE ONLY
PROBLEM WITH HISTORY AT THIS
POINT IS IT'S NOT REALLY TELLING
US ABOUT THE FUTURE, IS IT. SO
YOU I THINK THE FEELING RIGHT
NOW IS WE'RE AI AND DATA DATA
SERVICING DATA DEMAND, YOU KNOW,
WILL BE, CENTERS, IS MAINLY IN
THE EAST, RIGHT NOW. BUT BUT TO
PRETEND LIKE WE DON'T HAVE
SILICON VALLEY IN THE WEST IS I
THINK IT'S SHORTSIGHTED. AND I
THINK THAT'S REALLY A POLICY
ISSUE BECAUSE WE NEED TO GET OUR
ARMS AROUND HOW FAST THAT DATA
DEMAND IS GOING TO BE AND HOW
QUICKLY AI. AND EVERYTHING'S
BEEN EXPONENTIAL NOW. SO IT'S
HARD TO PLAN BASED ON THE PAST
FOR THE FUTURE IN THIS AREA. SO
I PERSONALLY WOULD SPEND SOME
TIME ON THAT. I OKAY, THAT'S ALL
I NEED. YEAH. YOU'RE PAYING
OKAY. THE OTHER QUESTION I'D ASK
IS WHO'S GOING TO PAY FOR THAT.
RIGHT. OKAY. BECAUSE OKAY OKAY.
YEAH YEAH. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SO MUCH. PLEASE. MR.
SENATOR THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, OR
ACCORDING TO THE HEADLINES,
SHOULD I SAY, MR. GOVERNOR?
THERE WE GO. GOOD TIMES. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ARE YOU
GOVERNOR TODAY? OH, OKAY. FINE
WOW. HE JUST WANTED. HE WASN'T
GOING TO TELL ANYBODY, SO I LET
THE. I MEAN, IT'S ALL OVER THE
PLACE RIGHT NOW, SO IT'S NOT
LIKE I'M TELLING SECRET OR
ANYTHING. I JUST WANT TO LET
EVERYBODY KNOW THAT, YOU KNOW,
IT'S A SPECIAL DAY THAT WE HAVE
THE GOVERNOR WITH US IN RULES
COMMITTEE. SO. YEAH, I WASN'T
GOING TO SAY THAT, BUT I DO
BELIEVE IT. BUT JUST AS
HANDSOME. NO YOU'LL TAKE THAT.
WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I CERTAINLY
WOULDN'T WANT YOUR JOB. I'VE
TOURED CAL ISO AND, YOU KNOW,
PAID ATTENTION TO WHAT THEY HAVE
TO DO, AND I CERTAINLY WOULDN'T
WANT THAT. RESPONSIBILITY ON MY
HEAD. SO THANK YOU FOR DOING IT.
MIGHT MAKE A SUGGESTION THE NEXT
TIME WE HAVE A HEARING LIKE THIS
THAT WE HAVE A GLOSSARY OF ALL
THE THREE LETTER AND FOUR
LETTER, ACRONYMS. YOU'VE DONE A
GREAT JOB OF EXPLAINING ALL OF
THEM, SO I APPRECIATE YOU TRYING
TO BRING US UP TO SPEED ON THAT.
AND I'VE GONE THROUGH YOUR THE
RESEARCH ON YOU. I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT YOU. SO MY QUESTION,
YOUR MY VOTE ISN'T CONTINGENT ON
MY QUESTION. SO I JUST WANT TO
GET SOME THOUGHTS. AND I'VE
ASKED A LOT OF FOLKS, THIS SAME
QUESTION ARE EITHER CEC OR PUC
OR THIS, YOU KNOW, CALIFORNIA IS
TRYING TO LEAD THE WORLD ON ZERO
EMISSIONS. AND GETTING TO THAT
POINT AND HAVING THAT GOAL, I'VE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO TOUR,
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT ARE,
EMBRACING SMALL, MODULAR NUCLEAR
REACTORS AS A PART OF THAT
SOLUTION AND PART OF THAT GOAL.
AND JUST WONDERING IF YOU HAD
SOME THOUGHTS ON THAT AND IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND SHARING THEM WITH
US ON IS THAT APPROPRIATE FOR
CALIFORNIA? SHOULD WE BE
THINKING ABOUT IT? YOU KNOW, I
KNOW WE'VE GOT A LONG WAYS TO GO
BEFORE WE WOULD EVER DO ANYTHING
LIKE THAT, BUT SHOULD WE BE
KICKING OFF THE CONVERSATION
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT THAT?
WELL, I CAN TELL YOU, TWO YEARS
AGO, BACK AT THE IRC MEETING OF
ALL THE RTOS, A PRESENTATION WAS
DONE ON THIS, I THINK IN THE
EAST, THEY'RE SERIOUSLY THINKING
ABOUT IT FOR SURE. FOR
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S TOUGH,
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD A CERTAIN
TRACK RECORD, WE HAVE A CERTAIN
HISTORY, AND I THINK WE
BASICALLY SAID THAT WE DON'T
WANT TO DO THAT ANYMORE. IN FACT,
WE BASICALLY FOUGHT TO CLOSE ALL
OUR, OUR NUCLEAR FACILITIES.
RIGHT. AND THE ONLY EXCEPTION WE
MADE TO THAT NOW IS DIABLO,
BECAUSE WE'RE HEDGING WITH
DIABLO. WHY THIS ENERGY
TRANSITION OCCURS. SO I THINK
THE GOOD NEWS FOR YOU IS IT WILL
PROBABLY HAPPEN IN THE EAST. THE
BAD NEWS IS I DON'T THINK I
DON'T SEE IT HAPPENING IN THE
WEST ANYTIME SOON. I SEE THE
ADOPTION OF HYDROGEN LIKE, YOU
KNOW, SEE IT COMING FROM DWP. WE
HAVE IPP AND I JUST THINK WE'RE
BANKING ON THAT. WE'RE BANKING
ON THAT BEING THE NEXT KILLER
APP, AREN'T WE? YEAH, WE ARE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. SENATOR
MADAM BOARD MEMBER AGAIN,
APPRECIATE YOU GOING IN DEPTH.
AND IT JUST SHOWS THE KNOWLEDGE
THAT YOU HAVE AND THE PASSION
THAT YOU HAVE FOR THE JOB WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT
THE GAP THAT WE SEE OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS AND GETTING OVER
THE HUMP OF POTENTIALLY, PEAK
CHALLENGES IN A DAY LIKE THIS,
OR GOING INTO A TWO WEEK PERIOD
OF EXTREME HEAT. DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT WE'RE A YEAR AWAY, TWO
YEARS AWAY, TO BE ABLE TO MEET
THAT PEAK DEMAND THAT WE SEE IF
YOU CAN KIND OF LOOK IN YOUR
CRYSTAL BALL? WE'VE HEARD WE'RE
ABOUT 24 MONTHS AWAY, BUT WHAT'S
YOUR TAKE ON THAT? THE WILD CARD
IS MOTHER NATURE, ISN'T IT? YOU
KNOW, IF I HAD A CRYSTAL BALL
THAT COULD TELL ME, I. I SIT
HERE WITH LAIRD AND SENATOR
GROVE, I THINK SIX YEARS AGO.
THEN AGAIN, THREE, THREE YEARS
AGO AND THE EXTREME HEAT WAS A
NEW PHENOMENA. AND NOW IT'S A
REGULAR OCCURRENCE. SO IT'S LIKE
YOU HAVE TO TAKE IT THE WAY I
WOULD LOOK AT IT IS I LIVED IN
SACRAMENTO AND I'VE NEVER SEEN
110 DEGREE DAY. YOU KNOW, I
THAT'S WHAT TODAY IS GOING TO
BE. RIGHT. AND WHEN YOU GO ON TO
CAL FIRE AND YOU SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE STATE RIGHT NOW,
IT'S SCARY. NOW THIS A LOT OF
THIS WAS PREDICTED, YOU KNOW, A
LOT OF A LOT OF ACADEMICS TOLD
US WE'D BE HERE RIGHT NOW. YOU
KNOW, DAN MAZMANIAN, I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU KNOW HIM FROM USC. I
REMEMBER I REMEMBER SEEING A
MODELING EXERCISE HE WENT
THROUGH TEN YEARS AGO THAT
SHOWED US THAT WE WOULD HAVE
FIRES UP AND DOWN THE STATE AND
SEA LEVEL RISE. OKAY. SO SAYING
ALL THAT, DO I THINK THAT WE HAD
SOME WARNING ABOUT WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW? WE DID. THE GOOD NEWS
IS THE GOOD NEWS IS AUGUST 2020
HAPPENED BECAUSE WE THERE WAS A
SHOTGUN MARRIAGE WITH CÁC, CPUC
AND CAISO THAT BOTH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
MADE CRYSTAL CLEAR. SO THE
ENHANCED WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH THOSE THREE ENTITIES IN THE
LAST 3 OR 4 YEARS MEANS THAT
WE'RE IN THE BEST SHAPE WE CAN
BE UNLOADING ADDITIONAL SUPPLY,
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE NEED IT.
GETTING INTO THOSE LONGER TERM
CONTRACTS RIGHT. AND THEN ALSO
FOCUSING ON IN-STATE BUILD OUT.
RIGHT, OF LOOKING AT THOSE PEAK
PERIODS. WELL, THIS IS WHAT THIS
IS WHAT WE HAVE THAT'S DIFFERENT
THAN 2020. WE NOW HAVE EIGHT
GIGAWATTS OF BATTERY STORAGE.
RIGHT. AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
1010. WHAT THAT DOES IS THAT
MITIGATES THAT NECK OF THE DECK
FROM 5 TO 10. THAT'S 5 TO 10.
NOW THEN BEHIND IT WE PUT WELL
WE PUT THE STRATEGIC RESERVE
DIDN'T WE. ONCE THROUGH COOLING
IS BEING HELD IN RESERVE. THAT'S
ANOTHER TWO GIGAWATTS. RIGHT.
AND THEN I WOULD SAY, BECAUSE OF
THAT COOL WEATHER AND BECAUSE WE
BUILT OUT A REGIONAL, A REGIONAL
ENERGY MARKET, WE NOW HAVE THE
BEST RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
WESTERN PARTNERS THAN WE'VE EVER
HAD. SO YOU KNOW, THEY WILL
IMPORT POWER TO US. THE OTHER
THING WE DID IS WE WERE BRINGING
IN MUCH MORE CONTRACTED IMPORTED
ENERGY, RIGHT. LIKE OUT OF NEW
MEXICO. SO RIGHT NOW, YOU KNOW,
YOU WANT ME TO SAY THAT IN TWO
YEARS, WE'RE GOING TO HIT ON
THAT MAGIC POINT WHERE WHERE
WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR JUST ON, ON
FOR YOU IS THAT LOOK, I THINK
THAT BOTTOM LINE IS FROM WHERE
WE WERE IN THE DEPTHS, AS YOU
JUST SAID, IN 2020. YEAH, TO
WHERE WE'RE AT NOW, WE'RE IN
MUCH BETTER SHAPE. YEAH, THERE'S
STILL MORE WORK TO DO, RIGHT? TO
BE ABLE TO, BUT IN PARTICULAR OF
THOSE DAYS, WHICH WERE
INCREDIBLY TOUGH, RIGHT? WE'RE
GOING THROUGH COVID. WE HAD
MASSIVE WILDFIRES AND EXTREME
HEAT AND BLACKOUTS. RIGHT.
IMPORTANT LESSON LEARNED, RIGHT?
YES. MUCH MORE COLLABORATION.
AND THEN PLANNING FOR THE WORST.
YES, WOULD YOU FEEL LIKE WE'VE
HIT BOTTOM? WE'VE STABILIZED AND
NOW WE'RE HEADING TOWARDS LONG
TERM RESILIENCY. WOULD THAT BE
AN INACCURATE STATEMENT? YES. AS
LONG AS MOTHER NATURE DOESN'T
UNLOAD SOMETHING SUPER FIERCE ON
US, WE SHOULD ANTICIPATE. YEAH,
100. OKAY. NO SERIOUSLY, I MEAN,
I MEAN, I'M JOKING, BUT I'M
SERIOUS. YEAH. OKAY. NOT
KIDDING. YEAH. NOT KIDDING. YEAH
YEAH. I'M SERIOUS. I'M
TERRIFIED. YEAH. I'M SOMEWHAT
TERRIFIED, BUT. BUT THAT'S OKAY.
IT'S SAN DIEGO HAPPY 4TH OF
JULY, EVERYBODY. HEY. SEE? THERE
WE GO. YEAH YEAH. ALL RIGHT.
YEAH. NO, I THINK I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO BE TO BE, TO FEEL
THE URGENCY OF THE SITUATION.
HOW'S THAT 100. YEAH. AND I
THINK AS SENATOR LAIRD ALLUDED
TO, I THINK THAT WHERE THE
SENATE WANTS TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS
IS WHERE WE CAN CONTROL THE
PROCESS. RIGHT. HOW DO WE BRING
ON LARGER SCALE, ENERGY PLANTS,
WHETHER IT'S GEOTHERMAL,
ONSHORE, OFFSHORE WIND,
COMMERCIAL GRADE SOLAR BATTERY
STORAGE AND THOSE ASSOCIATED
TRANSMISSION LINES, WHICH
CANDIDLY AND BEING FROM THE
NORTH COAST, THE ACHILLES HEEL
OF SO MUCH OF WHAT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO DO RIGHT, BE ABLE TO GET
THAT ENERGY INTO THE REST OF THE
MARKET HERE IN THE STATE. AND
WE'LL LET YOU CLOSE AND WE'LL
OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOVERNOR, THERE WE GO. OKAY
YEAH, I THINK I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT CAN HAPPEN
IS THE WAY THAT WE'VE ENHANCED
COOPERATION AT THE REGULATORY
LEVEL AND WITH STATE DEPARTMENT
AND AGENCY, WE NEED THAT SAME
LEVEL OF COMMUNICATIONS
HAPPENING ON THE PERMITTING
PROCESS BECAUSE WE HAVE THAT
EMERGENCY PERMITTING. BUT WHERE?
YES. OKAY. WHAT YOU MEANT WAS IN
THE NEXT TWO YEARS, WE HAVE
ENOUGH ROOM ON THE GRID TO
CONTINUE TO GROW AT THE AT THE
CLIP OF 6 TO 7GW. OKAY. BUT THEN
THERE'S GOING TO BE THIS MOMENT
WHERE IF WE DON'T HAVE NEW
TRANSMISSION, WE'VE RUN OUT OF
SPACE. IS THAT THAT'S WHAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT? OH, YEAH.
NO. OKAY. YEAH THAT'S TRUE. SO.
YES. SO FEEL LIKE IN, IN, YOU
KNOW, THE NEXT THREE YEARS WE
REALLY HAVE TO HAVE EXPEDITED
TRANSMISSION. YEAH. TO THE KEY
AREAS WE CAN BRING POWER ON TO
THE GRID AND MORE TO COME ON
THAT PROMISE. AND WE'RE GOING TO
HOPE IT'S COMING IN AUGUST. SO.
OH GOOD. YES, MADAM BOARD
MEMBER, THANK YOU. WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO NOW OPEN
IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. WE'RE
GOING TO WELCOME ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD
TO THE MICROPHONE. OAN IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STEP FORWARD. AT THIS TIME,
WE'RE LOOKING FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF MADAM BOARD
MEMBER, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU. HOWDY,
HOWDY. COME ON DOWN. HI. I'M NOT
USED TO BEING ALONE, GOOD
MORNING, TIFFANY PH¢N. ON BEHALF
OF A COUPLE OF ENTITIES IN
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT INTERSECT
POWER IN SUPPORT. MCE IS IN
SUPPORT AND ALSO CAL CA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD TO SEE YOU
TIFFANY. WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE AT THIS TIME HEARING
SEEING NO ONE STAND, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO LOOK FOR THOSE WHO MAY
BE IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? PLEASE ADVANCE TO
THE MICROPHONE AT THIS TIME,
SEEING NO ONE RISE, WE'RE GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
DISCUSSION, DEBATE OR A MOTION
AND MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
COMPANY TO THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
FULL CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU. SO
MUCH. MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
MADAM VICE CHAIR. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MAGUIRE A MAGUIRE? AYE.
GROVE GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. JONES A JONES. AYE.
LAIRD ON CALL 4 TO 0. THAT'S A
FOUR ZERO VOTE ON CALL. MADAM
BOARD MEMBER. FABULOUS JOB
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
WORK ON BEHALF OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HAPPY FOURTH. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YEAH. WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO DO, IF IT'S ALL RIGHT WITH
THE COMMITTEE, IS THAT WE'D LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO LIFT THE CALL ON A
FEW OF OUR ADMINISTRATIVE ITEMS,
IF IT WORKS FOR EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF YOU. WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH OUR BILL REFERRALS. AND AS
WE START LIFTING CALLS, WE'RE
GOING TO INVITE MR.
RECHTSCHAFFEN TO BE ABLE TO COME
FORWARD. LET'S START WITH BILL
REFERRALS. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO UNDER BILL REFERRALS.
ITEM NUMBER TWO. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL GROVE. GROVE. AYE. 5050
VOTE. FINAL VOTE. THAT ITEM IS
NOW CLOSED. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BE MOVING ON TO FLOOR
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS? GROVE.
GROVE. AYE. FIVE ZERO. THAT'S
A50 VOTE. FINAL VOTE FOR
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS. ACKNOWLEDGMENTS
ARE NOW CLOSED.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. COMMITTEE.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE TURNING
OUR ATTENTION TO MR.
RECHTSHAFFEN. WE WANT TO SAY,
MR. BOARD MEMBER, WELCOME, MR.
RECHTSHAFFEN IS HERE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
FOR APPOINTMENT FROM GOVERNOR
NEWSOM, MR. BOARD MEMBER, WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE. IT'S
NICE TO SEE YOU, SIR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. HAPPY EARLY FOURTH TO
YOU. WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE, WITH A KICKSTARTER OF YOUR
HOLIDAY WEEKEND AND RULES
COMMITTEE, YOU'RE LIVING THE
DREAM, YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
OPENING TESTIMONY TO THE
COMMITTEE. WE'RE GOING TO INVITE
YOU TO BE ABLE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
ANY FAMILY OR FRIENDS WHO ARE
HERE WITH YOU AND WHO ARE
WATCHING ONLINE. I WILL GIVE YOU
A 32ND WARNING WHEN YOU GET
CLOSE TO THAT TWO MINUTES, SIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. YOU HAVE HAD
A CAREER SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SENATOR
MCGUIRE. I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
MY WIFE, KAREN KRAMER, WHO'S
HERE. OUR KIDS ARE WORKING. I
DON'T THINK THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO LISTEN TODAY. I'M VERY
HONORED TO HAVE BEEN NOMINATED
TO THE BOARD BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
I HAVE SPENT MY ENTIRE CAREER IN
GOVERNMENT OR THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR WORKING ON ENVIRONMENTAL,
CLIMATE AND CLEAN ENERGY ISSUES.
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD PLAYS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ROLE IN
MEETING THE STATE'S CLEAN AIR,
CLIMATE AND EQUITY GOALS. I HOPE
TO BE ABLE TO MEANINGFULLY
CONTRIBUTE TO THESE EFFORTS AS A
BOARD MEMBER, I WELCOME YOUR
QUESTIONS AND DISCUSSION. MR.
BOHMER. THANK YOU. WE WANT TO
WELCOME KAREN AS WELL TO
COMMITTEE. IT'S WONDERFUL THAT
SHE'S HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN IT UP TO BE
ABLE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, PLEASE. MADAM VICE
CHAIR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. GOVERNOR. OH, THERE WE
GO. GOOD TIMES. THANK YOU. I
GUESS IT'S NOT MR. GOVERNOR.
IT'S JUST GOVERNOR. RIGHT JUST
THE TITLE. RIGHT. OKAY. THANK
YOU. GOVERNOR I APPRECIATE THE
TIME THAT YOU SPENT WITH ME
YESTERDAY. I DO APPRECIATE IT.
OR EXCUSE ME, MONDAY. I
APPRECIATE THAT TIME. WE TALKED
ABOUT SEVERAL THINGS. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WANTED TO GO OVER
WITH YOU IS THAT, YOUR EXPERTISE.
AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE I REALLY
DO BELIEVE IT. YOU HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND PRIOR SERVICE.
AND NOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. AND I THINK
THAT GIVES YOU A DISTINCT
ADVANTAGE, BECAUSE YOU HAVE, THE
KNOWLEDGE OF HOW LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR IMPACTS OUR
POLICIES, IMPACT THE SERVICE AND
HOW BEING ON THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IMPACTS THE COST
OF UTILITIES AND YOU HAVE THAT
PREVIOUS EXPERIENCE AND
KNOWLEDGE. ARE YOU CONCERNED OR
DO YOU HAVE SOLUTIONS ABOUT HOW
CALIFORNIA CAN MEET ITS CLEAN
AIR GOALS WITHOUT CREATING
BURDENS THAT WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT SMALL
BUSINESS OR THE MIDDLE CLASS,
AND CONTINUE TO INCREASE COST OF
GOODS AND GAS AND FUEL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I THINK WE
NEED TO BE VERY CONSCIOUS OF THE
MOST COST EFFICIENT WAYS TO
REDUCE CLIMATE, REDUCE CARBON
AND MEET OUR CLEAN AIR GOALS
THROUGH ALL OUR PROGRAMS, THE
ONES ADMINISTERED BY OUR ENERGY
AGENCIES AND THE CAISO AND THE
ENERGY IMBALANCE MARKET IS ONE
OF MANY TOOLS WE CAN USE TO HOLD
DOWN COSTS. PROGRAMS AT THE PUC
AND PROGRAMS THAT THE AIR BOARD
ADMINISTERS. WE NEED TO HAVE A
WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT APPROACH TO
DEAL WITH THE CLIMATE PROBLEM. I
THINK WE HAVE MORE OF THAT THAN
WE'VE HAD IN THE PAST, AND A
VERY IMPORTANT PART OF THAT
EFFORT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
RATES ARE AFFORDABLE TO PEOPLE
AND CLEAN ENERGY DEVICES AND
ELECTRIC VEHICLES CHARGING
ACCESS TO OUR CLEAN ENERGY,
INFRASTRUCTURE IS AFFORDABLE TO
PEOPLE. WE CAN'T LEAVE PEOPLE
BEHIND. SO IT NEEDS TO BE TOP OF
MIND IN EVERYTHING WE DO ACROSS
THE ADMINISTRATION. THANK YOU,
MONDAY, WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT,
NOT PUNITIVELY PUNISHING
INDIVIDUALS THAT DIDN'T HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY OR CONNECTIVITY TO
THE GRID, LIKE, FOR INSTANCE, WE
TALKED ABOUT FARMERS AND
ELECTRIC FORKLIFTS THAT DIDN'T
HAVE CONNECTIVITY FROM PGE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. HOW CAN YOU
PUNISH THEM FOR NOT MEETING THE
ELECTRIC ELECTRIFICATION GOALS
OF FORKLIFTS WHEN THERE'S NO
ELECTRICITY TO BE PROVIDED TO
THEM, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THAT I SHOULD
HAVE ASKED YOU WAS THERE'S
SIMILAR CONCERNS WITH OUR
RAILROAD SYSTEM. IT'S A GREAT
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
REGULATIONS THAT THE CAL AIR
RESOURCES BOARD, SENT LAST YEAR
REQUIRES A 30 BY 2035 TO HAVE
EMISSIONS FREE LOCOMOTIVES WHEN
MOVING THROUGH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IS THERE A
TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE? AND IS
THAT GOING TO BE FEASIBLE FOR,
US TO BE ABLE TO ATTAIN THAT? IS
THERE SOMETHING ON THE HORIZON
THAT YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT WE
DON'T. AND IF WE CAN'T ACHIEVE
THAT, WILL TRAIN STILL BE ABLE
TO MOVE GOODS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WELL, LET
ME RESPOND TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION. FIRST. WE CAN'T AND WE
SHOULDN'T. AND WE DON'T PUNISH
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T ELECTRIFY OR
MEET OUR REGULATIONS IF THEY
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN
ELECTRICITY OR ELECTRICITY,
PERIOD. AND BUILT INTO OUR RULES
AT THE AIR BOARD, INCLUDING THE
FORKLIFT REGULATION THAT WE JUST
ADOPTED, ARE EXEMPTIONS AND
EXCEPTIONS IN CASES WHERE
ELECTRICITY HASN'T BEEN BROUGHT
OR CAN'T BE BROUGHT FAST ENOUGH
TO THE PLACES WHERE PEOPLE NEED
TO FUEL UP, THAT'S A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT, PRAGMATIC SOLUTION TO
IMPLEMENTING THOSE RULES. I'M
NOT FAMILIAR IN DEPTH WITH OUR
LOCOMOTIVE RULE. I DO KNOW THAT
ALL OF OUR RULES NEED TO BE COST
EFFECTIVE. TECHNOLOGY AND
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE. SO I'M
CONFIDENT, EVEN THOUGH I WASN'T
ON THE BOARD AT THE TIME WHEN
THE BOARD TOOK THOSE ACTIONS, IT
HAD IN MIND. ARE THESE
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE? CAN
THEY BE REACHED IN THE TIME
PERIOD NECESSARY? BUT I THINK IN
ALL OF CARB'S RULES, THE
FORKLIFT RULE, I MENTIONED ALL
OF THE CLEAN VEHICLE RULES, CARB
STAFF BUILDS IN PRAGMATIC OUTS
AND EXCEPTIONS. WHEN TECHNOLOGY
DOESN'T MATERIALIZE AS FAST AS
WE THINK IT'S GOING TO, WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S BECAUSE OF COVID
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES OR DELIVERY
PROBLEMS OR ELECTRIFICATION
PROBLEMS, THAT'S CORE OF ALL THE
RULES THAT CARB ADOPTS. THANK
YOU. THE LAST QUESTION I HAVE IS
THAT THE SENATE REPUBLICAN
ASSEMBLY CAUCUSES SENT A LETTER
TO THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD REGARDING THE REGULATIONS
ON THE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARDS.
AND THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE IS
BECAUSE OF THE COST OF FUEL THAT
CARB'S REGULATORY PROCESS ON
THIS FOR THE LCFS COULD, BY YOUR
OWN ESTIMATE, YOURS MEAN CARB'S
OWN ESTIMATES INCREASE COST OF
FUEL BY $0.47 A GALLON. ARE YOU
CONCERNED THAT THE PROGRAM
REGULATIONS ARE GOING TO MAKE
THE GAS COST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GO UP? IS THERE
SOMETHING THAT YOU GUYS ARE
GOING TO DO TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THAT? AND I, I SAY THAT BECAUSE
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE ACROSS THE
DESK FROM ME, FROM STOCKTON, WE
REPRESENT THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
WE JUST DON'T GET ON A, I DON'T
KNOW, A TRANSIT BUS OR A
TRANSIT. YOU KNOW, RAIL CAR OR
SOMETHING. WE DRIVE WHERE WE GO.
AND SO WE'RE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED WITH THE MILES THAT WE
ACTUALLY DRIVE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY, COMPARED TO LIKE A SAN
FRANCISCO OR LOS ANGELES. SO ARE
YOU GOING TO ADDRESS THAT? AND
IF YOU ARE, CAN YOU TELL ME HOW?
WELL, I CAN'T TELL YOU EXACTLY
HOW, BUT I CAN TELL YOU.
ABSOLUTELY. WE CAN AND WILL
ADDRESS THAT. THE QUESTION OF
AFFORDABILITY OF ALL OUR
PROGRAMS, INCLUDING THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD, IS TOP OF
MIND. I THINK THE $0.47 ESTIMATE
THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO WAS
PROBABLY CONTAINED IN THE
STATEMENT OF THE ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS, THE SO-CALLED SORRY, I
APOLOGIZE, SENATOR JONES. I
DON'T WANT TO USE AN ACRONYM. I
CAN'T REMEMBER WHAT SYRIA CALLS
FOR, BUT IT'S AN ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS THAT AGENCIES ARE
REQUIRED TO UNDERTAKE BEFORE ANY
MAJOR RULE IS ADOPTED. AND I
THINK THAT WAS A WORST CASE
SCENARIO. IT'S VERY HARD FOR
MANY REASONS, TO PREDICT WHAT
THE IMPACT OF A PROGRAM IS GOING
TO HAVE ON GAS PRICES. THE
MARKET'S NOT TRANSPARENT. THE
MARKET'S SUBJECT TO MANY
ECONOMIC FACTORS BEYOND THE
CONTROL OF ANY STATE. THE PRICE
OF CRUDE OIL WORLDWIDE, REFINERY
PRODUCTION, REFINERY OUTAGES.
AND SO FORTH. WE'RE TRYING VERY
HARD TO GET A BETTER HANDLE AND
MORE TRANSPARENCY ON WHAT CAUSES
PRICES TO INCREASE. I WILL SAY
THE ENERGY COMMISSION, THEIR
DIVISION OF PETROLEUM MARKET
OVERSIGHT, RECENTLY CONCLUDED
THAT OVER THE PAST FOUR YEARS,
80% OF THE INCREASE IN GAS
PRICES THAT WE'VE SEEN IS A
RESULT OF REFINING DISTRIBUTION
AND MARKETING ACTIVITIES, NOT
THE RESULT OF ANY ENVIRONMENTAL
PROGRAMS. SO ALL THAT'S TO SAY
IS IT'S A VERY BIG AND IMPORTANT
PROBLEM. ONE, WE'RE NOT
NEGLECTING. THERE ARE COST CAP
PROVISIONS IN THE LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD, BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THIS ISSUE
VERY CAREFULLY. I ALSO WANT TO
POINT THAT THAT OVER THE LONG
TERM, THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
AS WE ELECTRIFY, CONSUMERS WILL
SAVE A LOT OF MONEY BECAUSE THE
COST OF OWNING AND OPERATING
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND FUELING
WITH ELECTRICITY IS MUCH CHEAPER
OVER THE LIFESPAN OF AN
AUTOMOBILE. IT DOESN'T IT
DOESN'T IN ANY WAY DEROGATE FROM
THE CONCERN YOU RAISE AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF DEALING WITH ANY
COST IMPACTS RIGHT NOW. THANK
YOU, SO I USUALLY AM A, YOU
KNOW, PRETTY SOLID ON WHERE I AM
ON CONFEREES AND VOTES AND
STUFF, BUT YOU, YOU SURPRISE ME.
YOU REMIND ME OF MY FRIEND, THE
SENATE PRO TEM EMERITUS, RIGHT?
IDEOLOGY. RIGHT. YOU KNOW,
IDEOLOGY. WE ARE IDEOLOGICAL. WE
ARE WAY ON DIFFERENT SIDES OF
THE SPECTRUM ON WHAT WE THINK
THE STATE'S ENERGY NEEDS SHOULD
BE AND WHERE SHOULD WE SHOULD GO
AND HOW YOU REGULATE THOSE
THINGS. BUT YOU ARE YOU LISTEN,
YOU TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION, YOU
TRY TO MITIGATE THOSE THINGS, TO
BRING PEOPLE MORE TO THE MIDDLE.
YOU JUST DON'T BLATANTLY GO,
THIS IS THE WAY IT IS. AND THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE MOVING FORWARD.
AND IF IT COSTS YOU MONEY, TOO
BAD YOU'RE NOT ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE, YOU PROVE THAT WITH THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU HAD WITH
MY DAIRY INDUSTRY, WHERE I HAVE
THE LARGEST DAIRIES, SOME OF THE
MOST DAIRIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, WHEN YOU ADDRESSED
THEIR DIGESTER ISSUE. AND EVEN
THOUGH I THINK THAT YOU STARTED
AT THIS SIDE AFTER YOU MET WITH
THE INDUSTRY AND HOW IT IMPACTED
THEM, YOU WERE VERY HELPFUL THEM
TO NAVIGATE THAT SYSTEM. SO I
APPRECIATE YOU BEING THE PERSON
THAT YOU ARE, AND I THANK YOU
FOR ANSWERING MY QUESTIONS. WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THOSE
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, MADAM VICE CHAIR.
SENATOR, THANK YOU. NICE TO SEE
YOU. AND WE HAD THE HONOR OF
MEETING THE FIRST TIME WHEN I
WAS IN THE STOCKTON CITY COUNCIL
AND THEN GOVERNOR, THEN ATTORNEY
GENERAL BROWN CAME IN AND
THREATENED TO SUE US ON OUR
GENERAL PLAN, SAYING THIS PLAN
IS BAD, AND CLIFF WAS HIS, SO
THEY WEREN'T. WELL, I WILL SAY I
WAS THE ONLY ONE WHO DID NOT
VOTE FOR THAT GENERAL PLAN, SO I
WAS ABLE TO BE HELPFUL. I THINK,
IN, IN GETTING A GOOD RESOLUTION
FOR ALL OF US. BUT BUT BUT CLIFF
WAS VERY INSTRUMENTAL IN,
HOPEFULLY KIND OF REWRITING THE
FUTURE OF, OF STOCKTON FROM
WHERE OUR, OUR SELF-INTEREST
WERE GOING. AND NOW NOW WE'RE
WHERE WE'VE TURNED. NOW AND
WHILE WE AND WHILE WE'RE, YOU
KNOW, DECENT SIZED CITY, WE
REMAIN, AN AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY
PART, RIGHT, SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS, IS AROUND HOW DO WE,
HOW HOW DO WE CONTINUE TO
PRODUCE THE BEST, THE BEST FOOD
IN THE WORLD HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AS, AS OUR IT COMES IN CONFLICT
SOMETIMES WITH A LOT OF OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. AND I KNOW OUR
FARMERS AND EVERYBODY FEEL A LOT
OF PINCHES AND IT'S NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF AIR AND WATER, BUT
THAT'S PART OF IT AND SOIL. SO
WHAT DO YOU THINK ARE THE
BIGGEST THINGS THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT IS GOING TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN A HEALTHY AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA? THAT'S A
BIG QUESTION. AND I A LOT OF
THAT IS HAS BEEN ACCOMPLISHED BY
OUR SISTER AGENCY, THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE, WHICH I THINK
HAS BEEN EXTREMELY THOUGHTFUL IN
TRYING TO MOVE THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY TO MORE SUSTAINABLE
PRACTICES THROUGH CLIMATE SMART
PRACTICES, THROUGH INCENTIVES
AND GRANTS AND MANY, MANY OTHER
PROGRAMS. ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS, DAIRY PLUS
AND SO FORTH. IT'S A TOUGH
QUESTION BECAUSE SOME PRACTICES
WILL HAVE TO CHANGE, BUT WE WANT
TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT WE HAVE A
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY. I THINK FOR THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD, ONE THING WE
CAN DO IN THIS RELATES TO WHAT I
WAS TALKING ABOUT WITH SENATOR
GROVE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
REGULATIONS ARE THOUGHTFUL AND
SMART, AND DON'T WIPE OUT
BUSINESSES. SO FOR EXAMPLE, IN
ONE OF THE BOARD'S MOST
IMPORTANT RULES, DEALING WITH
CLEAN TRUCKS, THE ADVANCED CLEAN
TRUCKS RULE, THERE IS AN
EXEMPTION FOR ANY BUSINESS WITH
FEWER THAN 50 VEHICLES OR LESS
THAN $50 MILLION IN ASSETS. AND
THEN EVEN FOR THAT, FOR SMALL
FLEETS OR FOR ONES THAT OPERATE
IN RURAL AREAS, THERE'S LONGER
COMPLIANCE TIMES. SO HOPEFULLY
THAT WILL GIVE A LONGER RUNWAY
TO AGRICULTURAL USERS. LIKEWISE,
WE DID SOMETHING SIMILAR IN THE
FORKLIFT RULE WE JUST ADOPTED.
WE GAVE A LONGER RUNWAY FOR
COMPLIANCE FOR CROP PROVIDERS.
AND WE ALSO HAVE MONEY IN THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE APPROVES
EVERY YEAR THAT SOME OF THAT
MONEY HAS GONE TO PROMOTE
SUSTAINABLE FARMING PRACTICES.
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
I THINK WE CAN WORK ON, BUT WE
NEED TO DO IT IN IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR OUR SISTER AGENCIES.
I'LL SAY ONE MORE THING. THE
GOVERNOR IS VERY AMBITIOUS
CONSERVATION GOALS AND
AGRICULTURAL LANDS ARE CERTAINLY
IDENTIFIED AS LANDS THAT CAN
PROVIDE CARBON SINKS FOR A LOT
OF EMISSIONS IN THE STATE. OKAY,
AND THEN JUST I HAVE A MAYBE
SIX, SEVEN TÍNH, I THINK THAT'S
THE NUMBER AREA IN MY DISTRICT.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT HOW, HOW YOU
THINK THAT PROGRAM IS ROLLING
OUT AND BECAUSE THERE'S STILL A
LOT OF, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
TENSION AND COMPLAINTS, IN THE
EJ COMMUNITY WITH OFFSETS AND
EVERYTHING, HOW ARE WE WORKING
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT IN, IN
REASONABLE WAYS? I KNOW ONE OF
THE, ONE OF THE ISSUES IS AROUND
MY PORT, AND PEOPLE ARE VERY
UPSET WITH THE PORT ALL THE
TIME, SO I GUESS THAT AND I
DON'T KNOW IF EVERY 617 IS BY A
PORT, BUT I KNOW THAT'S BEEN A
MAJOR SOURCE OF CONTENTION IN
OUR AREA. I THINK IT WAS A BOLD
STATUTE BY THE LEGISLATURE
BECAUSE FOR THE FIRST TIME WE
SAID WE'RE NOT JUST GOING TO OR
THE FIRST TIME IN THIS LEVEL OF
SOPHISTICATION AND DETAIL. WE
SAID, WE'RE NOT JUST GOING TO
ASSUME THAT IF AIR QUALITY RULES
BENEFIT THE STATE AS A WHOLE OR
THE REGION AS A WHOLE, BUT WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK AT LOCAL IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES AND SOURCES THAT ARE
NOT OTHERWISE REGULATED. AND
COMMUNITIES THAT CONTINUE TO
BEAR THE BRUNT OF
DISPROPORTIONATE HARMS. AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALLOCATED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR THE PROGRAM. AND I THINK
RIGHTFULLY SO. MY SENSE SO FAR
IS THAT THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
WORKING, BUT IT'S STILL GOING
THROUGH GROWING PAINS AND NEEDS
TO IMPROVE AND DO MORE. I THINK
IT'S RESULTED IN A LOT OF
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL
ENTITIES, NOT PERFECT. I
UNDERSTAND THERE HAVE BEEN
TENSIONS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE ARE. WE
JUST APPROVED LAST FALL A
BLUEPRINT FOR THE NEXT PHASE OF
AB SIX 117 AND IN THAT WE CALLED
ON THINGS LIKE PROVIDING MORE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
FOR THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS,
CONSULTING WITH THEM EARLIER SO
THAT THEY CAN DEVELOP RULES TO
RETROFIT EXISTING SOURCES TO
PROVIDE MORE MONEY FOR COMMUNITY
EMISSIONS MONITORING AND
REPORTING, TO DO COMMUNITY BASED
ENFORCEMENT. AND ALSO, THERE'S A
LOT OF COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
JUST BEEN ON THE EDGE THAT ARE
NOT GETTING FULLY FUNDED BY THE
PROGRAM. WE GAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES TO DEVELOP EMISSION
REDUCTION PLANS THAT ARE NOT AS
FORMAL OR BINDING AS THE FIRST
ROUND, BUT NONETHELESS CAN
ACHIEVE EMISSION REDUCTIONS. SO
I THINK IT'S A GOOD PROGRAM.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PROGRAM. IT'S
STILL GOING THROUGH A GROWING
PAINS. AND WE CONTINUE TO TRY TO
WORK AS CLOSELY AS POSSIBLE WITH
THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS AND
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AND THIS I
MEAN, THIS ISN'T REALLY PART OF
YOUR ROLE, BUT HOW DO YOU SEE DO
YOU SEE EVIDENCE OF US ALL
MOVING TOWARDS A DIRECTION WHERE
WE HAVE SHARED GOALS AND A
SHARED VISION? OF WHERE WE'RE
TRYING TO GO? WHEN YOU SAY US,
US? WELL, I GUESS I GUESS I
THINK ABOUT MY, MY 617 GROUP IN
STOCKTON, AND THEN I THINK ABOUT
MY, MY MOTHER IN LAW, WHO LIVES
IN THE OROVILLE AREA, WHO'S
CURRENTLY EVACUATED BECAUSE OF A
FIRE BUT SAYS, YOU KNOW, IT'S
JUST SUMMER. WE JUST CALL IT
SUMMER. LIKE KIND OF WITH A
BLINDNESS TO ANYTHING ELSE. AND
IT'S JUST A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE. RIGHT? IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN HOT. IT'S SUMMER VERSUS
OTHER PEOPLE. LIKE WE'VE GOT
PROBLEMS RIGHT? BECAUSE UNLESS
WE AGREE, UNLESS I THINK OF WHAT
THE ISSUE IS, IT'S REALLY HARD
TO WORK IN CONCERT TOGETHER
GOING FORWARD. WELL, THAT'S A
BIG QUESTION. YEAH, YEAH, PHD, I
KNOW, BUT IN CHAPTER FOUR. YEAH,
I THINK IT'S THE THINGS THAT
TROUBLE ME. WELL THEY, THEY
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT. I THINK
THERE'S SOME REASON FOR OPTIMISM
IN CALIFORNIA. THERE IS A LOT OF
SHARED INTENT AND COMMITMENT TO
OUR BIG GOALS. I THINK MORE THAN
THERE WAS 10 OR 15 YEARS AGO.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE
DONE, WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED A LOT.
WE SET A GOAL FOR 1.5 MILLION
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES IN 2012.
WE BEAT THAT 2 OR 3 YEARS AHEAD
OF TIME. THE GROWTH IN RENEWABLE
ENERGY IS ASTONISHING. IT'S THE
GROWTH IN STORAGE THAT MARY
LESLIE WAS TALKING ABOUT. WE'VE
MADE ENORMOUS STRIDES BEYOND
WHAT WE THOUGHT WE COULD MAKE.
WE HAVE A SINGULAR FOCUS IN
CALIFORNIA ON EQUITY ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
LEAVING COMMUNITIES BEHIND, AND
THAT WE KEEP THE ENERGY COSTS
AND OTHER COSTS AFFORDABLE. WE
ARE DEEPLY COMMITTED TO DOING
THAT. WE DID THAT THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC IN A WAY THAT NO OTHER
STATE DID. THAT PROVIDING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE'S HELP,
PROVIDING FOR FORGIVENESS FOR
PEOPLE WHO WERE BEHIND ON THEIR
UTILITY BILLS AND COMMITTING TO
MAKING GREATER ACCESS FOR OUR
PROGRAM. SO IT'S A BIG, TALL
TASK, AND CLIMATE IS VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT. IT'S HARD TO IT'S
HARD TO MAKE CHANGE. IT'S VERY
HARD TO MAKE CHANGE. BUT I THINK
THERE'S A SHARED I THINK THERE
ARE MORE THAN THERE HAS BEEN.
THERE'S A SHARED COMMITMENT TO
SOME OF THOSE BIG PICTURE GOALS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY
PLEASURE. THANK YOU SIR. LET'S
GO TO LEADER JONES. THANK YOU
SIR. IF YOU'VE DONE ANY RESEARCH
ON THE PANEL MEMBERS UP HERE,
YOU PROBABLY DISCOVERED THAT I'M
BEEN HIGHLY CRITICAL OF CARB
SINCE I FIRST GOT ELECTED HERE
IN 2010, AND NOT A BIG FAN OF A
LOT OF THEIR POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES AND ACTIONS. AND, AND
THAT'S NOT ANY ONE PERSON'S
FAULT. SO I'M CERTAINLY NOT
GOING TO. AND YOU'RE NEW, SO I
WOULD LIKE TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS
ON A COUPLE OF THINGS. AND I'VE
GOT A LIST OF STUFF, BUT I'M
ONLY GOING TO THE TOP TWO THAT
ARE TOP OF MIND FOR ME, RIGHT
NOW. VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED IS,
A TOPIC THAT'S, YOU KNOW, ACROSS
THE STATE. CARBS KIND OF LEADING
THE WAY ON THIS. THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO HAS BEEN TRYING TO
LEAD THE WAY ON THIS. AND YOU
KNOW, WE'RE AT A WE'RE AT A SPOT
NOW WHERE, IN MY OPINION, PEOPLE
THAT ARE DRIVING ELECTRIC
VEHICLES, FULLY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES THAT DON'T PURCHASE
GASOLINE ARE BEING SUBSIDIZED BY
THOSE OF US THAT DO BUY GASOLINE
THROUGH THE GASOLINE TAXES FOR
CONSTRUCTION AND MAINTENANCE OF
HIGHWAYS AND ROADS. IF WE
ACCOMPLISH THE GRAND GOAL THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS, GOVERNOR
NEWSOM HAS, OF ZERO EMISSIONS
VEHICLES BY 20, 35 OR 20,
WHATEVER DATE WE PICK, HOW ARE
WE GOING TO FUND HIGHWAY
CONSTRUCTION AND HIGHWAY
MAINTENANCE IF NOBODY'S BUYING
GASOLINE AND PAYING THE GASOLINE
TAX? AND SO THAT'S LONG TERM,
SHORT TERM. HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
EQUALIZE THE CURRENT SITUATION
OF GAS VEHICLES SUBSIDIZING
ELECTRIC VEHICLES CURRENTLY ON
THE ROAD? AND WHEN YOU SAY GAS
SUBSIDIZING ELECTRICITY, YOU
MEAN BECAUSE BECAUSE GAS
VEHICLES DON'T I'M SORRY. GAS
THE GAS TAXES PAYING FOR ROAD
CONSTRUCTION IS SUBSIDIZING
ELECTRIC VEHICLES, HAVING ACCESS
TO THOSE ROADS. THAT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT HAS COME ABOUT NOW BECAUSE
WE HAVE WE'VE DONE WELL AND
WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN HAVING
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ON THE ROAD,
BUT WE NEED TO HAVE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE.
YOU CAN ARGUE THEY HAVE LESS
WEAR AND TEAR ON THE ROADS, BUT
THEY CERTAINLY HAVE SOME WEAR
AND TEAR ON THE ROADS. I KNOW WE
AS A STATE, DIVE INTO THAT REAL
QUICK BECAUSE I WASN'T GOING TO
BRING THAT UP. BUT HOW DID HOW
WOULD YOU ARGUE THAT AN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE HAS LESS WEAR AND TEAR
ON THE ROADS THAN A GAS VEHICLE?
WELL, IT MAY BE SMOOTHER. RIDING
MAY BE LEAKING OIL. I'M I DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT, THE EXACT
DETAILS. OKAY. AND THE REASON I
ASK SPECIFICALLY FOR
CLARIFICATION ON THAT IS
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE MUCH
HEAVIER THAN GASOLINE VEHICLES
BECAUSE OF THE BATTERY SYSTEM.
AND SO I THINK SOME PEOPLE WOULD
ARGUE THAT THERE ARE MORE WEAR
AND TEAR ON THE ROADS THAN THE
GASOLINE, AND I'M NOT QUALIFIED
TO ANSWER. THAT'S FAIR. OKAY BUT
I STIPULATE I AGREE WITH YOU.
THEY HAVE SOME WEAR AND TEAR FOR
SURE. THANK YOU. THERE'S NO
QUESTION. THERE'S NO WE CAN'T
PRETEND OTHERWISE. AND WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT AN APPROPRIATE
PRICING STRATEGY SO THAT
ELECTRIC VEHICLES CONTRIBUTE TO
THE MAINTENANCE OF THE ROADS
THAT THEY USE. I KNOW WE, AS A
STATE HAVE BEEN THINKING ABOUT
THAT. I KNOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY HAS BEEN
BEEN DOING, ROAD PRICING PILOTS.
THERE'S DIFFERENT IDEAS FOR WHAT
THAT SHOULD LOOK LIKE. AND WE
NEED TO DO THAT. AND I WE'RE
MOVING IN THE SAME DIRECTION
THERE AS FAR AS WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING. BUT CURRENTLY, ALL OF
THE MODELS THAT I'VE SEEN AND
ALL OF THE EXPERIMENTS OR
CONVERSATION HAS BEEN ACROSS THE
BOARD, ON THIS VEHICLE MILEAGE
TAX OR THE TERM THAT YOU JUST
USED, I APOLOGIZE. IT'S BEEN
ACROSS THE BOARD, NOT SPECIFIC
TO EVS. AND SO ARE YOU. I THINK
I'M HEARING WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
ARE YOU SAYING THAT WE DO NEED
TO COME UP WITH A PROGRAM THAT'S
SPECIFIC TO EVS SO THAT THEY'RE
PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE OR, I
GUESS, EXPAND ON YOUR PERSONAL
THOUGHTS ON HOW WE WOULD DO
THAT. I DON'T KNOW THE
SPECIFICS, AND I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE YOU MAY BE REFERRING TO
SOMETHING IN THE WORKS THAT I
DON'T KNOW. I'M ASKING YOU IF
THERE'S I DON'T KNOW THE
DETAILS. I KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT IT. PEOPLE HAVE
IDENTIFIED ACADEMICS.
POLICYMAKERS HAVE IDENTIFIED
THIS AS A VERY REAL PROBLEM, AND
WE NEED TO COME UP WITH SOME
TYPE OF SOLUTION. I HAVE SEEN
DIFFERENT PILOTS IN PLACE
ADMINISTERED BY THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY MAY BE
LOCAL, REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES AS WELL, SEEING ABOUT
HOW IF YOU CAN CHARGE PEOPLE FOR
THE FOR THE AMOUNT OF MILES THAT
THEY USE THROUGH SOMETHING OTHER
THAN A GAS TAX, GAS VEHICLES
STILL PAY FULL REGISTRATION FEES
AT DMV. I MEAN, ELECTRIC
VEHICLES STILL DO THAT. SO
THAT'S, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE STILL
PAYING SOME COSTS OF OPERATING
THE SYSTEM, BUT OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE NOT PAYING THROUGH, A
GAS TAX. OKAY. AND THEN LAST
QUESTION, I THINK YOU RIGHTFULLY
SAID IN YOUR COMMENTS THAT WE
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN LOTS OF THESE
PROGRAMS, AND I WOULD AGREE WITH
THAT STATEMENT. YOU KNOW, ONE OF
THE THINGS I THINK THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS LED IN AND BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL IS CLEANING UP
THE AIR. AND I REMEMBER WHEN I
WAS A KID, IN CALIFORNIA, WE HAD
SMOG DAYS, EVEN IN SAN DIEGO,
WHERE WE HAD TO STAY IN THE
SCHOOL FOR THE DAY BECAUSE THE
AIR QUALITY WAS SO BAD. WE DON'T
HAVE THOSE ANYMORE. AND SO
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL. BUT HAVE
WE REACHED THE POINT NOW WHERE
WE'VE REACHED THE LAW OF
DIMINISHING RETURNS, WHEN NOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT REGULATING GAS,
MOERS GAS YARD TRIMMERS AND, AND
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT HAVE
CONTRIBUTE SO LITTLE, GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS TO THE AIR. BUT
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE
WATCHING CHINA, EMISSIONS BECOME
GREATER AND GREATER AND GREATER
TO THE POINT NOW WHERE A RECENT
REPORT SAYS THAT CHINA, THEIR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS NOW
EXCEED THE UNITED STATES AND THE
EUROPEAN UNION COMBINED. DOES
CARB HAVE A ROLE OR CAN WE
PRESUME A ROLE? CAN WE MAKE A
ROLE WHERE WE'RE GOING TO START
HOLDING CHINA ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE OUTRAGEOUS EMISSIONS THAT
THAT THEY'RE CAUSING ON THE
GLOBAL SCALE? WELL WE'RE
POWERFUL AT CARB, BUT WE WE'RE
NOT THAT POWERFUL THAT WE CAN
CONTROL CHINA. BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT, SENATOR JONES, TO
DISTINGUISH KIND OF SETTING YOU
UP BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR KEEPS
ARGUING THAT WE'RE LEADING THE
WORLD. THE GOVERNOR IS RIGHT
HERE, THE GOVERNOR NEWSOM, I
WANT TO SAY THAT YOU'RE THE REAL
GOVERNOR. I MEAN, COME ON. I
MEAN, GOVERNOR NEWSOM, I'M SORRY
I CAUSED ALL THIS CONFUSION THIS
MORNING REGARDING WHO'S THE
GOVERNOR. YOU KNOW, BUT HE MAKES
THESE GRAND PLANS AND GRAND
PROCLAMATIONS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
GOING TO DO THIS. CALIFORNIANS
DO THAT. WHY DON'T WE HAVE SOME
KIND OF TRADE AGREEMENT WITH
CHINA, LED BY CARB, TO START
HOLDING CHINA ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WHAT THEY'RE DOING TO THE AIR? I
DON'T THINK WE CAN DO THAT AS A
STATE, BUT LET ME WE CAN ENTER
TRADE AGREEMENTS. I TRIED TO DO
THE PARIS ACCORD WITHOUT WITHOUT
THE FEDS. BUT MORE TO THE POINT,
I WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION IN TWO WAYS. FIRST, I
WANT TO DISTINGUISH BETWEEN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION CONTROLS
AND JUST AIR QUALITY CONTROLS. I
DON'T THINK WE'RE REGULATING
LAWN MOWERS AND HANDHELD DEVICES
AND OTHER THINGS LIKE OR SMALL
SMALL APPLIANCES, SMALL SOURCES
FOR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
WE'RE DOING THAT FOR AIR QUALITY
REASONS. AND UNFORTUNATELY,
DESPITE THE INCREDIBLE SUCCESS
WE'VE HAD IN REDUCING SMOG, WE
STILL HAVE THE WORST AIR QUALITY
REGIONS IN THE STATE, IN THE
COUNTRY, IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND IN THE SOUTH COAST. AND WE
ARE AT A POINT OF SOMEWHAT
DIMINISHING RETURNS BECAUSE
WE'VE CONTROLLED THE BIGGEST
SOURCES. BUT NONETHELESS, THERE
ARE LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN AREAS IN THE STATE WHICH
VIOLATE THE HEALTH BASED
STANDARDS OF THE CLEAN AIR ACT.
AND IT'S OUR ROLE TO AND THE
ROLE OF THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
TO COME UP WITH CONTROL MEASURES
TO ADDRESS THAT. AND SOME OF
THEM MAY BE SMALLER AND SMALLER
SOURCES, BECAUSE WE'VE REGULATED
ALL THE, THE, THE LOW HANGING
FRUIT AND SO FORTH ON THE
QUESTION OF OUR ROLE VIS A VIS
CHINA, I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
HAS MADE CLEAR THAT THEY WANT
CALIFORNIA TO BE A LEADER ON IN
REDUCING CLIMATE. AND WE DO WHAT
WE CAN. WE ARE UNIQUELY
VULNERABLE TO THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER JUST ISSUED A
REPORT THIS WEEK SHOWING THAT
WE'VE LOST $7.5 BILLION. WE
SUFFERED $7.5 BILLION IN LOSSES
AND 500 DEATHS FROM HEAT WAVES
JUST IN THE PAST 5 OR 10 YEARS.
WE HAVE A SNOWPACK THAT IS VERY
VULNERABLE TO CLIMATE CHANGE,
ALONG COASTLINE. WE ALSO HAVE A
LOT OF BUSINESSES THAT HAVE COME
HERE TO PARTICIPATE IN
SUSTAINABLE CLIMATE CONTROL
EFFORTS. SO WE BENEFIT
ECONOMICALLY FROM SOME OF THAT.
I THINK WE DO OUR PART AND
HOPEFULLY WE SET AN EXAMPLE FOR
PROVINCES AND OTHER
JURISDICTIONS AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT WE CAN'T OBVIOUSLY CONTROL
EVERYTHING. AND CERTAINLY NOT
THE ECONOMY OF SOMETHING LIKE
CHINA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR. LEADER. WE'RE GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR GROVE,
AND WE'RE GOING TO LOOK TO
MICHAEL. IF YOU DON'T MIND. I
THINK THE MICS ARE PRETTY LOW.
IF YOU DON'T MIND TURNING UP THE
MEMBER MICS AS WELL. SORRY ABOUT
THAT. THANK YOU. SO I JUST I HAD
A FOLLOW UP QUESTION BECAUSE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON
MENTIONED A MITIGATION, AND SO I
DID HAVE A IT REMINDED ME OF A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT WAS
GOING THROUGH THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE, WHERE I'M THE VICE
CHAIR, ABOUT FOREIGN OWNED LAND,
I'M SORRY, FOREIGN OWNED LAND.
I'LL TIE THAT TO YOU IN JUST ONE
SECOND. SO THERE WAS A BILL
GOING THROUGH THE BUILDING ABOUT
FOREIGN OWNED LAND, AND IT WAS
INTERESTING TO ME THAT PURSE AND
INVESTMENT PORTFOLIOS CAME IN IN
STRICT OPPOSITION OF THAT,
BECAUSE THEY HAD INVESTMENTS IN
CANADA, WHO OWNED FARMLAND IN
OUR CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE
REASON WHY THEY WERE UPSET IS
BECAUSE THEY WERE ALLOWED TO
PRESENT A PIECE OF THAT
PORTFOLIO AS GREEN, BECAUSE THEY
WERE GETTING CARBON OFFSETS,
CANADA ALLOWS CARBON OFFSETS FOR
FARMING TREES AND EVEN THOUGH
THE TREES ARE IN CALIFORNIA,
CANADA'S PORTFOLIO ALLOWS IT TO
BE CREDITED AS GREEN BECAUSE
THEY ALLOW THE TREES TO HAVE
CARBON OFFSETS. BUT WHAT WE
DIDN'T REALIZE DURING THAT
HEARING, IT'S NOT RECIPROCAL. SO
EVEN THOUGH FOREIGN COUNTRIES
HAVE LAND IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THAT ALLOW THEM TO HAVE GREEN
OFFSETS BECAUSE OF THE TREES,
HOW COME CARB DOESN'T ALLOW OUR
FARMERS TO HAVE MITIGATION FOR
EVERY TREE THEY PLANT? FOR A
CARBON OFFSET LIKE YOU DO A
PRIVATE BUSINESS OR A HOME THAT
PLANTS TREES? WELL, WE DO HAVE
WE DO ALLOW OFFSETS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE STRICT
PROTOCOLS TO MAKE SURE THAT
OFFSETS RESULT IN GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. THAT WOULD NOT
OTHERWISE OCCUR, THAT THEY'RE
VERIFIABLE, ADDITIONAL AND
ENFORCEABLE. I'M I'M NOT AWARE
OF ANY PROTOCOL THAT DEALS
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE USE OF
FARMERS PLANTING TREES ON THEIR
LANDS, BUT WE CERTAINLY HAVE
OFFSET PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE EARNING CREDITS BY
REFORESTING AND MAINTAINING FOR
NOT MAINTAINING FOREST, BUT
REFORESTING, PREVENTING
DEFORESTATION, AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AUTHORIZED THE
USE OF OFFSETS IN OUR CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM IN 2017, THE
LEGISLATURE SAID YOU CAN HAVE UP
TO 8% OF YOUR COMPLIANCE. I
BELIEVE IT'S UP TO 8% OF YOUR
COMPLIANCE CAN BE ACHIEVED
THROUGH OFFSETS. 4% HAS TO BE
ONLY, NO MORE THAN 4% CAN BE OUT
OF CALIFORNIA. SO THE
LEGISLATURE HAS INDICATED A
PREFERENCE FOR MORE OF THOSE
OFFSETS TO OCCUR WITHIN
CALIFORNIA. SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION AGAIN, JUST TO CLARIFY
IS, IS THAT FARMERS HAVE TREES
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND THEY
PLANT THEM, BUT THEY'RE NOT
ENTITLED TO THOSE OFFSETS. WE
ALL KNOW THAT TREES ARE A
NATURAL CARBON SEQUESTRATION.
YOU HAVE SOME OF THE LARGEST
FARMING COMMUNITIES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. THE TOP THREE
FOOD PRODUCING COUNTIES IN THE
WORLD, AND, OUR FARMERS DON'T
HAVE THE SAME RECIPROCAL, OFFSET
THAT OTHER COUNTRIES GET FOR
CREDIT IN THAT. AND WE DON'T GET
THE SAME RECIPROCAL OFFSETS THAT
THEY DO FOR DEFOREST OR FOREST
ATION. AND SO WHY IS THAT? AND
WHY WILL NOT CARB ALLOW THEM TO
USE THE CAP AND TRADE, CARBON
OFFSETS AND THE OTHER OFFSETS IN
THE SCOPING PLAN, TO OFFSET
EVERY TREE THEY PLANT. I CAN'T
COMMENT ON WHAT THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM IN CANADA BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE REQUIREMENTS
ARE, BUT WE APPROVE OFFSETS
BASED ON LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION.
AND IN AB 32, THE ORIGINAL CAP,
THE ORIGINAL CLIMATE CHANGE BILL
PASSED IN 2006, THE LEGISLATURE
WAS VERY CLEAR IT WANTED IT
WANTED TO LIMIT OFFSETS TO ONLY
THOSE THAT ARE ADDITIONAL AND
ENFORCEABLE, REAL, QUANTIFIABLE.
AND THERE'S A FIFTH REQUIREMENT.
SO IN ORDER FOR THAT, IN ORDER
TO EFFECTUATE THAT LEGISLATION,
CARB HAS SET UP A RIGOROUS
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT ANY
BODY WHO'S ENGAGING IN
VOLUNTARY, REDUCTIONS, LIKE
POTENTIALLY THE SITUATION YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT, MEETS, MEETS,
STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS SO THAT
THE BENEFITS OF THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE REAL. SO I DON'T KNOW THE
SPECIFICS OF THE TYPE OF
ACTIVITY THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. I DON'T KNOW IF THE
FARMERS HAVE TRIED TO GET A
PROTOCOL APPROVED THROUGH CARB,
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO BE THAT
STRINGENT TO MEET LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTION. SO LET ME ASK IT IN A
DIFFERENT WAY, YOU SAID REAL AND
QUANTIFIABLE. IF AN IF A FARMER
PRINTS, I DON'T KNOW, 60 ACRES,
360 ACRES OF ALMONDS OR
PISTACHIOS OR WHATEVER.
AVOCADOS. AND THEY'RE ALL GREEN
LEAVES. THEY'RE ALL NATURAL
CARBON SEQUESTRATION, CAN YOU
FIND OUT WHY CARB, WHICH YOU SIT
ON THE BOARD OF, WOULD NOT ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE OFFSETS FOR EVERY
TREE THAT THEY PLANT BECAUSE
THEY'RE MEETING THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. THEY'RE REAL.
THEY'RE REAL TREES. AND IT'S A
REAL OFFSET. AND IT'S
QUANTIFIABLE AND YOU CAN COUNT
IT. WELL, ANOTHER BIG YEAH, I
CAN CERTAINLY FIND OUT. AND IF
YOU SEND THE SPECIFICS OF THE
PARTICULAR PROGRAM THAT PEOPLE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT, A BIG
HURDLE TOO, THOUGH, IS THAT THE
OFFSETS HAVE TO BE ADDITIONAL.
YOU HAVE TO SHOW THAT IN THE
ABSENCE OF AN OFFSET PROGRAM,
THE PLANNING OF THE TREE, THE
ACTIVITY WOULD NOT HAVE
OTHERWISE OCCURRED. IN OTHER
WORDS, WE DON'T WANT TO GIVE
PEOPLE CREDIT FOR DOING WHAT
THEY'RE DOING ANYWAY BECAUSE
THAT DOESN'T RESULT IN AN
ADDITIONAL REDUCTION IN GHG
EMISSIONS. AND RECALL THAT OUR
CLIMATE GOALS, AB 32, SB 32, SB
1279 REQUIRE DRAMATIC REDUCTIONS
IN THE IN THE CLIMATE EMISSIONS.
SO WE CAN'T SIMPLY KEEP THINGS
STATUS QUO. GUESS YOU HAD TO YOU
HAD AN ALMOND ORCHARD. YOU'RE
KEEPING IT THAT WAY. WE WANT
ADDITIONAL REDUCTIONS,
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS TO BE
REALIZED TO MEET THOSE GOALS.
THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING THAT.
THANK YOU, GOVERNOR, FOR
ALLOWING ME TO DO THAT. GEEZ.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM VICE
CHAIR, MR. BOARD MEMBER, I'M
GOING TO GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND BEFORE WE DO, I WANT TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. I'M JUST GOING TO
VERY BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD AND LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
DISCUSSION ON FUEL PRICES. AND I
KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'LL
FOLLOW UP ON HERE LATER. AND
THEN THE OTHER ISSUE OF BIOFUEL
INVESTMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND GREATLY
APPRECIATED OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO SIT DOWN, HAVE A
CONVERSATION, AND WE'LL FOLLOW
UP SOMETIME IN JULY AND GREATLY
APPRECIATED THAT. THANK YOU. OF
COURSE. NO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND MISS CHIN WANTED TO
SAY ALWAYS THANK YOU TO LISA.
WILL BE FOLLOWING UP GETTING
THAT SET UP. WHAT WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO DO IS OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. ANY AND EVERY
ONE OF YOU ARE WELCOME. MR.
BROWN IS IN THE HOUSE, DOING TO
THE MIC. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
FIRST AND LAST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. GOOD MORNING, MR.
PRO TEM. NICE TO SEE YOU. LOUIS
BROWN, HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED BIOFUELS
ALLIANCE, WE REPRESENT THE
PRODUCERS OF BIODIESEL AND
RENEWABLE DIESEL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF MR. RICHARDSON'S
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MICHELLE
KANELLIS, ON BEHALF OF UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE APPOINTMENT OF
CLIFF SHORES, APPOINTMENT TO
CARB. WE'VE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
MEETING WITH HIM MULTIPLE TIMES
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS ON LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD, AND HAVE
BEEN IMPRESSED BY HIS THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO THE POLICY. AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO REFERENCE SPECIFIC
ENVIRONMENT. SUPPORT ON THEIR
BEHALF AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. JULIE
MALINOWSKI, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION,
TESTIFYING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF,
DIRECTOR, CORRECTIONS
APPOINTMENT, VICE CHAIR GROVE,
YOU HIT ON EXACTLY WHY WE
ACTUALLY LIKE WORKING WITH HIM.
AND ARE HERE TODAY, WHICH IS
BECAUSE HE IS 100% COMMITTED TO
BETTER AIR QUALITY AND
DECARBONIZATION, AND WE CAN
AGREE TO DISAGREE ON THINGS, BUT
HE'S ALWAYS THE DOOR IS ALWAYS
OPEN, AND HE'S ALWAYS KEEPING
THE CONVERSATION GOING ON WHERE
THE SHADES OF GRAY ARE IN A
WORLD THAT ISN'T VERY BLACK AND
WHITE IN SOLUTIONS. SO THAT IS
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANKS, JULIE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, JOHN WINGER HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS, ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION,
APPRECIATE ALL THE DIALOG THAT
WE'VE HAD, AND LOOK FORWARD TO
FUTURE CONVERSATIONS ON A LOT OF
DIFFICULT POLICY ISSUES. THANKS
THANKS, JOHN. HEY. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, VICTORIA ROME WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT FOR THE
REASONS STATED. THANK YOU. GOOD
TO SEE YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING,
VIRGIL WELCH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CARBON SOLUTIONS
COALITION, VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT MR. RICHARDSON, I'VE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE TO WORK WITH CLIFF
FOR MANY YEARS AND PROUD TO
SUPPORT HIM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. GOOD MORNING.
MORNING. MR. PRO TEM AND
SENATORS JASON BRYANT, ON BEHALF
OF THE WESTERN UNITED DAIRIES,
WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
APPOINTMENT. THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. HOPE THE KIDS ARE
WELL. GOOD MORNING. MORNING,
TIFFANY FAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
INTERSECT POWER IN SUPPORT CAL
CA IN SUPPORT IN MCE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING. BILL MAGAVERN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR, IN
SUPPORT BOARD MEMBER
RECHTSHAFFEN BRINGS VALUABLE
EXPERTISE AND A COMMITMENT TO
CLEANING UP OUR AIR, PROTECTING
OUR CLIMATE, AND PROVIDING
EQUITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU. BILL. HI. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. MICHAEL
PIMENTEL, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION, HAPPY TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF DIRECTOR RICHARDSON'S
APPOINTMENT. I PERSONALLY HAVE
WORKED WITH DIRECTOR
RECHTSHAFFEN FOR MORE THAN A
DECADE ACROSS HIS TIME IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AT THE CPUC
AND NOW AT THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. KNOW HIM TO BE
HIGHLY PRAGMATIC, VERY
APPROACHABLE, VERY THOUGHTFUL IN
HIS DELIBERATIONS, AND HE BRINGS
TO HIS ROLE AT CARB A LOT OF
FIRSTHAND EXPERTISE ON WHAT'S
GOING TO BE NECESSARY FOR US TO
MAKE THE TRANSITION TO ELECTRIC
TECHNOLOGIES ACROSS ALL MODES
VIABLE. AND SO, AGAIN, OFFER OUR
FULL SUPPORT FOR THE DIRECTOR
AND HIS APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
MORNING. HI. GOOD MORNING,
NICOLE HUTCHINSON WITH CALSTART
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HEY, GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING,
MEGAN MICKELBERG, ON BEHALF OF
VALLEY CLEAN AIR. NOW, WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE ADVICE
AND SUPPORT THAT THE BOARD
MEMBER HAS PROVIDED TO THE
VALLEY, HIS UNIQUE EXPERIENCE
LEADING IN CLIMATE WORK AND
VARIETY OF SENIOR ROLES ACROSS
MULTIPLE ADMINISTRATIONS GIVES
HIM VALUABLE PERSPECTIVE IN HOW
CALIFORNIA CAN ADMINISTER ITS
CLIMATE GOALS. SO THANK YOU AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. HEY. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS THEO PIMCO'S
REPRESENTING THE CALPINE
CORPORATION VERY MUCH IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF MR. HOFFMAN HERE
TODAY. I'D ALSO LIKE TO SAY
PERSONALLY, I REPRESENT A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES, AS SOME
OF YOU KNOW, AND IN MY DEALINGS
WITH HIM HAS BEEN VERY FAIR,
VERY REASONABLE AND ALWAYS SEEMS
TO FIND AN ANSWER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE GOING
TO DO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO
MAY BE IN SUPPORT. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD AT THIS
TIME. THIS IS GOING TO BE LAST
CALL FOR INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. SEEING NO ONE STAND,
WE'RE NOW GOING TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STEP FORWARD AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO ONE STAND, WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE, SEE IF THERE'S ANY
LAST MINUTE DISCUSSION, DEBATE
OR WE'LL WELCOME A MOTION. SO
MOVED. WE HAVE A MOTION BY MADAM
SENATOR. SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
TRULY APPRECIATE IT. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
GROVE GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN EGGMAN.
AYE. JONES. JONES. NOT VOTING.
LAIRD ON CALL THREE. IT'S A30
VOTE. WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THAT
ON CALL FOR SENATOR LAIRD. BOARD
MEMBER. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
KAREN. THANK YOU. AND HAPPY
FOURTH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. NOW, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, WE'RE GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO OUR FINAL
APPOINTMENT OF THE DAY. WILL
THEN BE GOING INTO EXECUTIVE
SESSION. WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME
MR. MARINO SAN MARINO WELCOME,
SIR, DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
DATA AND INNOVATION. AS MR.
MARINO MAKES HIS WAY DOWN TO THE
DAIS. MARINO, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE YOU ADVANCE TWO MINUTES
WORTH OF OPENING TESTIMONY
DURING THAT OPENING. PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO WELCOME ANY FAMILY,
FRIENDS WHO ARE HERE WITH YOU OR
WATCHING ONLINE. AS YOU GET
CLOSE TO THAT TWO MINUTES, I'LL
GIVE YOU A 32ND PROMPT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. RUNNING THE NEW
AGENCY, VERY GRATEFUL FOR ALL
THE HARD WORK. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AS A LIFELONG
CALIFORNIAN, I AM HUMBLED BY
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE MY
STATE, AND I THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING MY APPOINTMENT AS
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF DATA
AND INNOVATION. I'M GRATEFUL TO
THE GOVERNOR FOR ENTRUSTING ME
WITH THIS DUTY AND TO SECRETARY
TONG OF THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY FOR HER
FEARLESS LEADERSHIP AND
GUIDANCE. I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE MY WIFE, JENNY, AND MY
MOTHER, WHO ARE HERE WITH US
TODAY, OUR SON HOPPER IS FOUR
YEARS OLD AND STILL TOO MUCH OF
A WILD MAN TO INVITE INTO THIS
CHAMBER, SO HE'LL BE WATCHING
FROM PRESCHOOL THIS MORNING,
JENNY, I CAN SAFELY SAY THAT IF
IT WERE NOT FOR YOUR LOVE AND
UNWAVERING SUPPORT, I WOULD NOT
BE SITTING BEFORE THIS
DISTINGUISHED COMMITTEE TODAY.
THANK YOU. AND I LOVE YOU. AND
OF COURSE, I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THE TEAM AT ODI. THANK YOU FOR
ALL REMINDING ME EVERY DAY WHAT
IT MEANS TO BE A HUMBLE AND
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT.
INNOVATION IS NOT ABOUT THE
LATEST AND GREATEST TECHNOLOGY.
INNOVATION HAPPENS WHEN SOMEONE
SEIZES THE OPPORTUNITY OF A NEW
IDEA OR TECHNOLOGY, AND
DISCOVERS HOW IT CAN BE USED TO
IMPROVE OUR LIVES. BY
DEFINITION, INNOVATION MUST BE
HUMAN CENTERED. THIS IS WHY YOU
WILL HEAR EVERY GREAT BUSINESS
LEADER INSIST THAT THEIR COMPANY
SUCCEEDS, AND THEIR ABILITY TO
INNOVATE DEPENDS ON BEING
CUSTOMER OBSESSED. PRIOR TO
JOINING STATE SERVICE, I WORKED
AS A DATA JOURNALIST, EMPOWERING
CONSUMERS WITH THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS AT CRITICAL MOMENTS IN
THEIR LIVES, SUCH AS BUYING A
HOME OR TAKING A NEW JOB. I DID
THIS BY BECOMING CUSTOMER
OBSESSED AND USING EVERY DATA
POINT AT MY DISPOSAL TO DEEPLY
UNDERSTAND THEIR CHALLENGES AND
CREATE STRATEGIES TO EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS. I CAME TO
PUBLIC SERVICE AS A VOLUNTEER
DURING THE PANDEMIC, AT A TIME
WHEN INNOVATION AND HOW OUR
GOVERNMENT SERVES THE PUBLIC WAS
DESPERATELY NEEDED MORE THAN
EVER BEFORE, WE HAD TO EMPATHIZE
WITH PEOPLE IN ORDER TO SERVE
THEM EQUITABLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
THIS IS WHEN I WAS INTRODUCED TO
ODI, AND I WAS AMAZED TO FIND
THAT AN ORGANIZATION WAS
DESIGNED WITHIN STATE GOVERNMENT
TO DO EXACTLY THAT. ODI MISSION
IS TO PARTNER WITH STATE
DEPARTMENTS IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THE TOOLS, TRAINING AND SUPPORT
THEY NEED SO THAT THEY MAY
BECOME CUSTOMER FOCUSED, TRULY
UNDERSTAND THEIR CUSTOMERS, AND
DELIVER EQUITABLE AND
EXCEPTIONAL SERVICES. WE MUST
MOVE AWAY FROM THE MINDSET THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO COME TO US TO GET
THE SERVICE THEY NEED, AND
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE A DUTY TO
MEET PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE AND
SERVE THEM QUICKLY, EFFECTIVELY
AND IN A WAY THAT ULTIMATELY
RESPECTS THEIR DIGNITY. THIS
CONCLUDES MY OPENING REMARKS,
AND I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE FOR ME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE APPRECIATE THOSE.
THAT OPENING TESTIMONY. I HAVE A
THREE YEAR OLD AT HOME, AND I
KNOW WHAT YOU MEAN. THEY COULD
BE A HELLION AT TIMES. MY
GOODNESS, IT'S GOOD STUFF.
THEY'RE WITH YOU ALL RIGHT.
ABSOLUTELY. BUT, TALK TO ME IN
20 YEARS. HEY, THERE WE GO.
EXACTLY. BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
MEETING HOPPER. MY GOODNESS, WHY
DON'T WE TURN IT OVER TO
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS? QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE AT THIS
TIME, PLEASE. MADAM VICE CHAIR,
THANK YOU AGAIN. GOVERNOR. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. AND I
APPRECIATE YOU, DURING COVID, I
WAS IN LEADERSHIP AND WE HAD
HEARD ABOUT YOU AND HOW YOU JUST
CAME IN AND TRIED TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO HELP FIX THINGS, EVEN
VOLUNTARILY. AND IT JUST SHOWS
THE CHARACTER OF WHO YOU ARE,
FIRST OF ALL, NOT WANTING
ANYTHING IN RETURN, BUT JUST
YOUR IMMEDIATE CONCERN FOR THE
STATE AND THE SITUATION WE WERE
IN, TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
OPERATE FROM A LEVEL OF NOT IN
PERSON, IF THAT MAKES SENSE, I
DO HAVE ONE QUESTION. DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT ODI OR THE
OFFICE OF DATA INNOVATION?
BECAUSE I KNOW PEOPLE HATE
ACRONYMS, WILL ENGAGE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE
LEGISLATURE, TO DETERMINE IF ANY
OF THE CHEN, IE, RELATED
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES REQUIRED
OR PROCESSES REQUIRED BY THE
GOVERNOR BY EXECUTIVE ORDER NEED
TO BE CODIFIED, AND YOU'RE A
PERSON THAT I MEAN, WHAT YOU SAY
WILL BE VERY IMPACTFUL BECAUSE I
MEAN, I THINK YOU'RE THE RIGHT
NOW, THE SMARTEST PERSON IN THE
ROOM WHEN IT COMES TO THIS. AND,
SO WE'LL HAVE TO LISTEN TO WHAT
YOU HAVE TO SAY AS AN ANSWER,
BUT I THINK THAT WHO YOU ARE AS
A PERSON OF CHARACTER WILL
BALANCE THAT SITUATION,
REGARDLESS OF WHO'S CALLING THE
SHOTS OR NOT, IF THAT MAKES
SENSE. ABSOLUTELY. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, I APPRECIATE
THAT QUESTION VERY MUCH, IT
CERTAINLY IS VERY TIMELY. AND,
WE ARE REALLY TAKING, I WANT TO
SAY, A WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT
APPROACH AT THIS TIME AS IT
RELATES TO OUR RESPONSE TO
GENERATIVE AI, CERTAINLY WITHIN
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
AND MY COLLEAGUES AT CAL, H.R,
DGS AND THEN OUTSIDE OF OUR
AGENCY AT GO-BIZ AND ELSEWHERE,
WE ARE, IMPLEMENTING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER, ON
ON GEN AI AND DOING SO WITHIN
THE PURVIEW OF GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS. SO WE RECOGNIZE THAT
IT IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO
PROVIDE THE GUARDRAILS SO WE CAN
HAVE SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE GEN AI
WITHIN THE STATE, IT'S
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THAT WE
DEVELOP THESE SKILLS WITHIN THE
STATE WORKFORCE BECAUSE AS IT
WILL BE USED FOR ANY NUMBER OF,
NEFARIOUS PURPOSES OR BY BAD
ACTORS, OUR STATE WORKFORCE AND
OUR STATE PROFESSIONALS HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO USE THIS TOOL IN KIND
SO WE CAN ADDRESS THOSE
CHALLENGES IN ADDITION TO ALL OF
THE GREAT BENEFITS THAT IT CAN
POTENTIALLY BRING TO HOW WE
SERVE CALIFORNIANS, ALL OF THAT
IS TO SAY THAT WHETHER OR NOT
THE REGULATIONS OR GUIDELINES
THAT WE'RE PUTTING INTO PLACE
OUGHT TO BE CODIFIED, I THINK
YOU ALL WILL DECIDE, AND I AM
ALWAYS HAPPY TO ADVISE ON THESE
ISSUES. WE ARE CURRENTLY, HAVING
REGULAR, LEGISLATIVE ENGAGEMENT
SESSIONS WITH, WITH YOU ALL AND
YOUR STAFF, I BELIEVE, NOW ON A
MONTHLY BASIS, AS WE WORK
THROUGH THE EXECUTIVE ORDER. AND
I, OF COURSE, AM ALWAYS
AVAILABLE TO DISCUSS ANY
SPECIFIC CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE ON THE TOPIC.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM VICE
CHAIR. LET'S TURN IT OVER TO
PLEASE, SENATOR. THANK YOU. IN
AND WELCOME IN, YOUR RESPONSES
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE REALLY
HIGHLIGHTED TRAINING, AND YOU
HIGHLIGHTED THE CAL ACADEMY,
WHAT ROLE DO YOU THINK TRAINING
IS GOING TO PLAY? AND WHERE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE THE
WORKFORCE IN FIVE YEARS BECAUSE
OF THE TRAINING YOU'RE WORKING
ON, AS OPPOSED TO NOW? THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION. I APPRECIATE
IT VERY MUCH BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT TRAINING IS ABSOLUTELY AT
THE CORE, ONE OF OUR STRONGEST
STRATEGIES FOR GOVERNMENT
TRANSFORMATION THAT WE HAVE,
ANOTHER STRATEGY THAT WE HAVE IS
BRINGING ON NEW TALENT TO THE
STATE, WHICH WE WILL NEED TO
DEVELOP NEW STRATEGIES FOR, AND
MAY BE A LONGER TAIL. SO I
BELIEVE THAT TRAINING IS OUR
FASTEST AND MOST EFFECTIVE WAY
TO REALIZING THE TRANSFORMATION
THAT THAT WE WANT TO SEE. THE
TRAINING THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED
CURRENTLY HAS TO DO WITH OUR
RESPONSE TO GOVERNOR, THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
EMBEDDING EQUITY, WHERE, ODI WAS
REQUIRED TO DEVELOP A SET OF
SERVICE DELIVERY STANDARDS THAT
SUPPORT EQUITY. AND OUR FIRST
RESPONSE IN DOING SO WAS SETTING
A PLAIN LANGUAGE STANDARD, A
STATEWIDE PLAIN LANGUAGE
STANDARD THAT ALL CALIFORNIA
FACING, MATERIALS BE WRITTEN IN
AN EIGHTH GRADE READING LEVEL.
AND SO WE REALIZE AS A, AS A
HUMAN CENTERED ORGANIZATION THAT
WE CANNOT SET FORTH A STANDARD
SUCH AS THAT WITHOUT PROVIDING
THE GUIDANCE AND THE TRAINING.
SO, SO OUR DEPARTMENTS AND OUR
WORKFORCE CAN IMPLEMENT THAT.
WHEN WE WHEN WE FIRST DESIGNED
THAT CURRICULUM AND RELEASED IT
ON CALTRANS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
CAL AIR, IT, I WANT TO SAY SOLD
OUT, BUT IT'S OFFERED FREE TO
ALL STATE WORKERS. BUT IT SOLD
OUT WITHIN HOURS, AND WE'VE
TRAINED OVER 500 STATE STAFF AND
WE'VE MOVED FORWARD WITH MAKING
IT A ASYNCHRONOUS ONLINE
TRAINING. AND SO NOW WE IMAGINE
THAT THAT'S GOING NOW GOING TO
BE AVAILABLE AT ANY TIME TO ANY
MEMBER OF STATE STAFF THAT THAT
WANTS TO TAKE THAT NOW, THAT'S
JUST ONE FIRST STEP. BUT IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT FIRST STEP
BECAUSE IT'S IT IS, A LOW LIFT,
HIGH IMPACT IN THAT IF WE CAN
BRING OUR WORKFORCE ALONG AND
BEING ABLE TO AND EMPOWER THEM
WITH THE ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE
IN SUCH A WAY THAT CALIFORNIANS
CAN UNDERSTAND THE SERVICES
WE'RE OFFERING TO THEM, THAT CAN
MAKE A VERY BIG DIFFERENCE. I
THINK THE THING IS, IS, YOU
KNOW, I WHEN I WAS A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MANAGER, WE DID A
BOOT CAMP FOR MANAGERS BECAUSE
THEY JUST PROMOTED AND THROWN
INTO IT, AND WE DID A 32 HOUR
TRAINING ON DISCIPLINE
PERFORMANCE EVALUATION. ADA
BUDGETING, ALL THE KINDS OF
THINGS THEY WERE EXPECTED TO DO.
AND WE HAD ALL THESE WAYS WE
COULD MEASURE IT, SUDDENLY WE
DIDN'T HAVE APPEALS TO THE CIVIL
SERVICE COMMISSION BECAUSE
PEOPLE WERE HANDLING IT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. HOW WOULD YOU
MEASURE WHETHER THIS TRAINING IS
WORKING? WHAT MEASUREMENTS WOULD
TELL YOU THAT IT'S ACHIEVED WHAT
YOU WANTED IT TO ACHIEVE? THAT'S
A VERY GOOD QUESTION. AND SORT
OF A COMPLICATED ONE IN THAT
PART OF THE TRAINING THAT WE
NEED TO OFFER IS, IN FACT, THIS
PERFORMANCE MEASUREMENT AND
PERFORMANCE MANAGEMENT APPROACH,
IN ADDITION TO TRAINING ON
MODERN ANALYTICS AND CUSTOMER
SUCCESS METRICS, IMPLEMENTING
CUSTOMER SUCCESS METRICS, FOR
DEPARTMENTS TO IMPLEMENT IN
THEIR BUSINESS OPERATIONS SO
THEY CAN BEGIN MEASURING THEIR
SUCCESS IN A MORE EFFECTIVE AND
MODERN WAY. THAT IS A BIG GAP
THAT EXISTS IN THE STATE
CURRENTLY, AND WE UNDERSTAND WHY,
BECAUSE GOVERNMENT IS HAS NOT
TYPICALLY BEEN APPROACHED AS A
BUSINESS. WE DON'T HAVE A
MARKETING DEPARTMENT. WE'RE THE
ONLY GAME IN TOWN. IT'S A GOOD
THING. SENATOR GROVE ALREADY
ASKED YOUR QUESTION. YOU YOU
WOULD BE TEEING HER UP RIGHT
NOW. WE DON'T HAVE. WE'RE THE
ONLY GAME IN TOWN, SO WE NEED TO
TRAIN DEPARTMENTS IN ORDER TO
MEASURE THEIR SUCCESS. AND SO
IT'S REALLY GOING TO BE BY
EXTENSION OF THAT. AND WHETHER
OR NOT THEY ARE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT AND
DEMONSTRATE, HOLD THEMSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE AND DEMONSTRATE THAT
THEY ARE BEING SUCCESSFUL IN
MEASURING THEIR SUCCESS, BEING
TRANSPARENT ABOUT WHERE THERE
ARE GAPS AND THEN TAKING ACTION
TO FILL THOSE. AND WE WILL BE
THERE TO SUPPORT THEM ALL. THE
WHOLE WAY. OKAY, I THINK IT JUST
GOES OUT WITHOUT SAYING. WE'RE
INTERESTED IN THAT. WE'RE
INTERESTED IN HOW YOU MEASURE IT
AND HOW YOU SEE THAT IT WORKS
OVER TIME BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IT
WILL CIRCLE BACK AND INSTRUCT
WHAT YOU HAVE IN THE TRAINING,
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE NOT ADDRESSING
WHAT PEOPLE NEED AND NOT
CHANGING, SORT OF SOME OF THE
PROBLEM AREAS, YOU'LL KNOW.
WELL, THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE
THE RESPONSES TO THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. SENATOR. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION PLEASE, SIR. HI AND
WELCOME, THANK YOU. SO HELP ME
UNDERSTAND TO THE WILL YOU
DECIDE ON A PROJECTS OR WILL THE
DEPARTMENTS BRING A PROJECT TO
YOU? RIGHT. LIKE SO WHEN WE PASS
A BILL AND THEY SAY, SAY, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO DO
OUTREACH, WE'RE GOING TO DO ALL
THESE THINGS, I'M ALWAYS SAYING,
WHAT ARE WE DOING BESIDES
PUTTING A DASHBOARD UP? BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIA IS LOOKING AT
ANYBODY'S DASHBOARD. RIGHT. AND
SO WE'RE VERY PROUD OF OUR
DASHBOARDS. I DON'T THINK IT'S
EFFECTIVE. SO WILL YOU LIKE, DO
A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF ALL
THE DEPARTMENTS AND HOW THEY'RE
ACHIEVING CUSTOMER SERVICE, OR
WILL THEY COME TO YOU AND ASK
YOU FOR ASSISTANCE? OR WILL WE
DO IT SORT OF. ALL OF THE ABOVE,
AS A NEW ORGANIZATION, WE ARE
TRYING DIFFERENT WAYS TO
APPROACH BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
AND CUSTOMER ENGAGEMENT, THINGS
LIKE THAT, I WILL SAY THAT
WHAT'S I THINK TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION, WHAT'S CORE TO OUR
APPROACH IS HEALTHY SKEPTICISM
AND ENSURING THAT WE APPROACH
EVERY PROBLEM, EVERY ENGAGEMENT
WITH THOROUGH, WITH THOROUGH
DISCOVERY AND PROBLEM
DEFINITION. SO I'LL GIVE YOU A
PERFECT EXAMPLE. THE DEPARTMENT
OF TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL CAME
TO US AS THE OFFICE OF DATA AND
INNOVATION AND ASKED FOR US TO
BUILD THEM AN APP. THEY WANTED
US TO BUILD THEM AN APP TO
COLLECT PUBLIC COMMENT. AND WE
SAID, WE UNDERSTAND THE OUTCOMES
THAT YOU WANT. YOU WANT MORE
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT, YOU WANT MORE
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT FROM
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES, WHICH
IN ORDER TO MEET THEIR EQUITY
TARGETS, BUT WE'RE NOT QUITE SO
SURE THAT AN APP IS NECESSARILY
THE ANSWER. AND SO BEFORE
EMBARKING ON BUILDING AN APP,
WHICH WE CERTAINLY COULD DO, WE
DID USER RESEARCH AND WE WENT
INTO THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
WERE SERVING AND WE DID RESEARCH
ON WHETHER OR NOT APPS WERE
ACTUALLY BEING ADOPTED AND
DOWNLOADED BY THESE COMMUNITIES.
SO, SO ON AND SO FORTH. WE
DISCOVERED IN THAT RESEARCH THAT
THEIR PRIMARY ENGAGEMENT
MECHANISM WAS A LETTER IN THE
MAIL. AND SO THAT THAT LETTER IN
THE MAIL, YOU KNOW, IN THE
DIGITAL AGE, IT'S VERY
FRUSTRATING FOR SOMEONE LIKE
MYSELF BECAUSE TO SENATOR
LAIRD'S QUESTION, WE CAN'T WE
DON'T KNOW IF THEY OPENED THE
LETTER. WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY
RECEIVED THE LETTER, AND IN A
DIGITAL ENGAGEMENT ENVIRONMENT,
WE CAN TELL IF THEY OPENED THE
EMAIL, IF THEY AND IT ACTUALLY,
STREAMLINES THAT FUNNEL OF
COMMUNICATION BECAUSE THE ACTION
THAT WE'RE ASKING THEM TO TAKE
PROVIDE US A COMMENT, IT GREATLY
REDUCES THEIR TIME TAX BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE TO SIT DOWN,
WRITE A LETTER, PUT A STAMP ON
AN ENVELOPE AND GO TO THE POST
OFFICE. THEY THEY CLICK THE
BUTTON THAT SAYS CLICK HERE TO
COMMENT. AND SO THROUGHOUT THAT
PROCESS IT WAS A VERY SUCCESSFUL
PILOT. WE INCREASED THEIR
ENGAGEMENT AND WE HELPED THEM
MEET THEIR GOALS. BUT WE FOUND
THE SOLUTION BY TALKING TO THEIR
USERS. AND THIS IS THIS IS A
VERY COMMON THEME ACROSS
GOVERNMENT. WE ARE OFTEN
APPROACHED ALREADY WITH A
SOLUTION AND SO WHAT'S IMPORTANT
ABOUT HOW WE'RE APPROACHING OUR
WORK AND HOW WE'RE
COMMUNICATING? TO STATE
DEPARTMENTS, HOW WE CAN ENGAGE
WITH THEM, IS THAT YOU HAVE TO
BE OPEN TO A PROBLEM DEFINITION.
YOU HAVE TO BE OPEN TO DISCOVERY
THAT YOU HAVE TO BE OPEN TO A
DIFFERENT WAY OF DOING THINGS.
SO IN ESSENCE, YOU'RE BRINGING
MORE, MORE SYSTEMIC THINKING
INTO THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT WHAT'S
THE GOAL, WHO'S THE CUSTOMER,
WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO DO? THAT
IS THE GOAL. AND THIS ALSO
RELATES TO THE TRAINING ASPECT,
BECAUSE THAT APPROACH, IN
ADDITION TO A MINDSET SHIFT AND
A CULTURE SHIFT, ALSO REQUIRES
CERTAIN SKILL SETS THAT
DEPARTMENTS DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE IN TERMS OR TOOLS, IN TERMS
OF HOW HOW DO I DO THIS USER
RESEARCH? WHAT IS THE INTERVIEW
GUIDE? LOOK LIKE? HOW DO I MAKE
SURE I'M DOING IT EQUITABLY, HOW
DO I REACH THE PEOPLE THAT I
NEED TO REACH AND THOSE SKILLS
AND THOSE PROCESSES ARE, WELL
ESTABLISHED IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR, AND THEY KNOW HOW TO
REACH THEIR CUSTOMER. AND
UNDERSTAND THEM, AND SO WE NEED
TO BRING MORE OF THOSE
APPROACHES IN, INTO OUR, OUR
STATE DEPARTMENTS. AND HOW IS IT
GOING HIRING PEOPLE TO HELP YOU
MEET THIS GOAL. SO ODI IS SMALL.
AND WHAT I LIKE TO SAY IS THAT
NO MATTER HOW LARGE YOU WERE TO
GROW OUR ORGANIZATION, WE WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE THIS
LOFTY GOAL OURSELVES. THAT'S
ACTUALLY NOT THE POINT. THE
POINT IS THAT WE'LL NEVER BE
ABLE TO BE THE CAPACITY WE HAVE
TO BUILD THE CAPACITY. AND SO
AGAIN, THIS IS WHY TRAINING IS
SO CORE TO OUR MISSION AND TO
OUR MODEL, AND IT REALLY IS
CO-CREATION. SO WHAT WE NEED TO
DO IS HIRE ENOUGH SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT TO
BE ABLE TO PAIR WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS TO SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS ALONGSIDE THEM. CREATE
PLAYBOOKS, CREATE TRAININGS, AND
THEN HOPE TO SCALE THAT ALONG
THE WAY. AS FAR AS HIRING WITHIN
ODI, WE'RE HAVING GOOD SUCCESS,
WE HAVE A MIXTURE OF STATE STAFF
AND THOSE FROM THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND MANY FOLKS WHO ARE AT
ODI RIGHT NOW WERE ACTUALLY
ACTUALLY IN MY SHOES. WERE
VOLUNTEERS, DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND THEN CAME ON AND HAVE BEEN
WITH US THIS WHOLE TIME. I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
MR. LEADER, SIR, JUST A QUICK
QUESTION ON YOUR RESUME. I
NOTICED AN INTERESTING CHANGE
OF, OF CAREER BACK IN IN 2018,
2020 AND JUST WANTED TO AND I'M
NOT ASKING ANYTHING PERSONAL OR
ANYTHING YOU DON'T WANT TO
SHARE, JUST WANT TO SAY, JUST
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO KIND
OF TALK ABOUT THAT AND SEE WHAT
LED TO THAT, CAREER CHANGE. ARE
YOU YOU'RE SPEAKING TO THE
CHANGE JOURNALISM INTO, THE
DIGITAL INNOVATION GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY? SURE. YES.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION. I'M
I AM DELIGHTED AT THAT CAREER
CHANGE BECAUSE I FEEL THAT I'VE
FOUND MY PATH. WHEN I WAS FIRST
WORKING IN THE TECHNOLOGY SPACE,
DATA JOURNALISM REALLY IS
WORKING WITHIN THE CONTENT
MARKETING DIVISIONS OF THESE
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES. WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS USING THE DATA THAT WE,
THE BIG DATA THAT THEY HAVE AT
THEIR FINGERTIPS TO PROVIDE
INSIGHTS TO CUSTOMERS THAT ARE
VALUABLE IN THEIR OWN RIGHT, BUT
ALSO BUILD TRUST FOR THE BRAND
AND HELP TO CONVERT THEM INTO
CUSTOMERS. RIGHT. AND SO THESE
WERE MISSION DRIVEN, TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES, WHICH I WAS DRAWN TO.
AND I FELT THAT IN DOING MY
WORK, I WAS SERVING THE PUBLIC
AS WELL AS HELPING THEM SERVE
THEIR BOTTOM LINE, I DIDN'T KNOW
THAT DOING THIS KIND OF WORK WAS
POSSIBLE UNTIL I VOLUNTEERED.
AND WAS INTRODUCED TO ODI, WAS
INTRODUCED TO THE
CROSS-FUNCTIONAL TEAMS AT THE
STATE WHO WERE DOING THIS
INNOVATIVE WORK, AND I. I JUST
COULDN'T LOOK BACK AT THAT
POINT, BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT I KNOW I HAVE THE SKILLS
AND EXPERIENCE THAT CAN MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN THE
WAY WE DELIVER SERVICES AT THE
STATE. AND SO AT THIS POINT, I
FEEL A DUTY TO THIS SERVICE,
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION,
SENATOR. WELCOME. AND THEN JUST
ON A KIND OF SPECIFIC QUESTION
TO THE OFFICE AND CAN YOU KIND
OF DIVE INTO JUST A LITTLE BIT
AND I DON'T, MAYBE JUST
ENCAPSULATE HOW BEST YOU CAN,
YOU KNOW, YOUR OFFICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY APPEAR
TO HAVE SOME OF THE SAME
RESPONSIBILITIES AND MAYBE EVEN
SOME OF THE SAME, PROCESSES,
PROJECTS AND OUTCOMES. AND SO,
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT IS DUPLICATING
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACIES, WHICH
I DON'T SUPPORT. OF COURSE, SO
HOW DO YOU AND I KNOW YOUR, YOUR
OFFICE IS NEW, SO YOU'RE
PROBABLY STILL TRYING TO FIGURE
ALL THIS OUT. WHERE ARE YOU AT
ON THAT? WHERE DO YOU SEE IT
GOING, CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT A
LITTLE BIT? SURE. YES. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION. IT'S AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION. IT'S A
QUESTION THAT OUR COLLEAGUES IN
OTHER STATE DEPARTMENTS HAVE,
AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR OUR
ORGANIZATION TO CONTINUE TO
DISTINGUISH AND TELL OUR STORY.
SO, THE STATE WORKFORCE
UNDERSTANDS HOW TO WORK WITH US
AND K¾T MOST EFFECTIVELY. OUR
PURVIEW AS IT RELATES TO
TRAINING THE STATE WORKFORCE TO
IMPROVE BUSINESS PROCESSES THAT
INCLUDE THE VOICE OF
CALIFORNIANS, DESIGN REDESIGN
SERVICES, AND THEN BUILD THE
TOOLS AND THE SKILLS IN
ANALYTICS TO MEASURE THAT
SUCCESS IS SQUARELY IN OUR
PURVIEW. THAT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS REALLY OWNED BY ANY
OTHER DEPARTMENT ACROSS THE
STATE. WHERE WE REALLY DO
CONNECT AND WHERE IT'S VERY, A
VERY GOOD RELATIONSHIP IS THAT
MANY OF THE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE'RE
INTRODUCING AS PART OF THESE
PROCESSES NEED TO BE SCALED.
THEY NEED STRONG SECURITY AND
GOVERNANCE, AND WE CAN PARTNER
WITH K¾T IN THAT REGARD IN A
VERY EFFECTIVE WAY. AGAIN, WE'RE
SMALL K¾T HAS A GREAT BREADTH OF
POWERED WORKFORCE. AND SO WE ARE
VERY COMPLEMENTARY IN THAT
REGARD. AND WOULD YOU WOULD YOU
SAY THAT THAT ARRANGEMENT AT
THIS POINT IN TIME IS NEUTRAL,
POSITIVE NEEDS SOME WORK, VERY
POSITIVE, VERY POSITIVE. SURE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. LEADER.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, MR.
DIRECTOR. WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
IS WE'RE GOING TO OPEN IT UP FOR
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT, IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS POTENTIAL
APPOINTMENT, IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD AT THIS TIME. HEY.
GOOD MORNING. NICE TO SEE YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. COURTNEY JENSEN, ON
BEHALF OF THE TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE APPOINTMENT OF
JEFFREY MORENO AS DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF DATA AND
INNOVATION. TECH. CCA'S MISSION
IS TO BUILD BETTER PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN GOVERNMENT AND INDUSTRY
BY PROMOTING TRANSPARENCY AND
BEST PRACTICES TO HELP MODERNIZE
DIGITAL SERVICES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS, AS YOU HEARD WITH
SIGNIFICANT EXPERIENCE IN BOTH
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC SECTORS,
DIRECTOR MORENO HAS THE VISION
AND LEADERSHIP SKILLS TO DRIVE
INNOVATION ACROSS CALIFORNIA
STATE PROGRAMS MORE THAN EVER,
CALIFORNIA NEEDS STRONG
LEADERSHIP IN TECHNOLOGY, DATA,
AND DESIGN AS PROGRAMS MODERNIZE
TO MEET THE GROWING EXPECTATIONS
OF THOSE WHO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
DIRECTOR MORENO HAS THE TALENT
AND CHARACTER TO INFLUENCE
CHANGE THROUGH STRATEGY,
COLLABORATION, AND TEAM
BUILDING, REPRESENTING MORE THAN
50 MEMBER COMPANIES RANGING FROM
THE WORLD'S MOST RECOGNIZABLE
TECHNOLOGY BRANDS TO LOCAL
CONSULTING FIRMS THAT SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES, TECH CA IS
PROUD TO SUPPORT HIS
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. GOOD TO SEE YOU. LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE AT THIS TIME, WE'RE
GOING TO DO A LAST CALL FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE AT THIS TIME, WE'RE
GOING TO DO A LAST CALL. SEEING
NO ONE RISE. LET'S BRING IT
BACK. MEMBERS, IF THERE IS
DISCUSSION, DEBATE OR MOTION.
THANK YOU. SIR, I'D LIKE TO MAKE
A MOTION TO MOVE DIRECTOR MORENO
TO THE FULL FLOOR FOR
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MADAM VICE CHAIR. MR. CHAIRMAN,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME, YOUR
EFFORT, YOUR HARD WORK ON BEHALF
OF THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOUR FAMILY
IS HERE AS WELL. IT MEANS THE
WORLD TO US. MADAM SECRETARY,
LET'S CALL THE ROLL. MCGUIRE.
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. GROVE AYE.
GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE
JONES. JONES. AYE. LAIRD 40
ZERO. THAT'S FOUR ZERO VOTE.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THAT ON
CALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH. HOPE
YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL FOURTH AND
SOME WELL-DESERVED DOWNTIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BEST TO
HOPPER. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, COMMITTEE.
AND TO THOSE WHO ARE HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE, WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
IS THAT EVERYONE WHO IS HERE IN
COMMITTEE IS ON EACH VOTE. SO
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO
IS, RECESS INTO THE EXECUTIVE
SESSION. WE'RE GOING TO GET THIS
COMMITTEE ON VOTES. THEN MEMBERS
COULD LEAVE, WILL THEN GO BACK
INTO REGULAR SESSION. WAIT FOR
MR. LAIRD TO COME BACK FROM
LABOR COMMITTEE, GET HIS VOTE,
AT REGULAR SESSION. GET HIS VOTE
AND EXECUTIVE SESSION, AND THEN
GO BACK IN AND OFFICIALLY
ADJOURN. SO, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, WE'RE GOING TO NOW GO
INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION. THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK INTO
REGULAR SESSION, SO WE'LL LAY
OUT THE GAME PLAN. WE'RE WAITING
FOR SENATOR LAIRD TO BE ABLE TO
COME BACK. HE'S ON HIS WAY.
WE'LL GET SENATOR. SENATOR LAIRD
IS TROMPING THROUGH THE HEAT.
SENATOR LAIRD IS BACK FROM THE
HEAT. WE'RE GOING TO PLAY. THERE
WE GO. JUST ON THE LAST ONE. YES.
QUESTION ON THE CROSS-BORDER AND
PRACTICING REP SHOP. NO. AND I
SEE EXACTLY. BEFORE WE GET INTO
IT, WE'RE GOING TO DO THE HOW
HOT IS IT GAME. HOW HOT IS IT
OUT THERE, SENATOR LAIRD? I
DON'T KNOW, I WAS JUST HOT 115.
YOU JUST SAID, ALL RIGHT, HEY
THERE. YOU GO. THAT'S RIGHT.
NICE. NO. HEY, THERE WE GO. IT
IS DEFINITELY GOING TO BE WARM
TODAY. ALL RIGHT, SO WHAT WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO IS WE'RE
GOING TO RUN THROUGH ONE A, B
AND C WE'RE GOING TO RUN THROUGH
ONE A, B AND C. THAT WILL BE IN
OUR REGULAR SESSION. WE'RE THEN
GOING TO RECESS. GO BACK INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION. WE'RE GOING
TO GET SENATOR LAIRD'S VOTE ON
EXECUTIVE SESSION, COME BACK
INTO REGULAR SESSION AND
ADJOURN. IT SAYS IT'S 9595
DEGREES. THERE WE GO. SEE BALMY.
ALL RIGHT. HERE WE GO. WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING INTO GOVERNOR
APPOINTEES. OUR FIRST ONE IS
ITEM ONE, A MARY LESLIE. CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS? AYE. BAIRD.
AYE. 5 TO 0 FIVE ZERO. VOTE THAT
APPOINTMENT IS INCLUDED AND OUT.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON
TO ITEM ONE B MR. RECHTSHAFFEN
FOR THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO. CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
303030? CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS? LAIRD. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. 4040 VOTE. THAT ITEM
IS CLOSED. FINAL VOTE AND OUT.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM ONE C MR. MARINO, DIRECTOR
OF THE OFFICE AND DATA
INNOVATION. CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER
LAIRD. AYE LAIRD. AYE. 5050
VOTE. FINAL VOTE WILL CLOSE IT
DOWN. AND MR. MARINO IS OUT AND
HEADING TO THE FLOOR. WE ARE NOW
GOING TO GO BACK INTO OUR
EXECUTIVE SESSION, WE'LL GET A
QUICK VOTE, COME BACK INTO
REGULAR SESSION, SAY, HAPPY.
SO I DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH, TO THE AMAZING RULES CREW.
TWO MORE MEETINGS LEFT
EVERYBODY? TWO MORE MEETINGS
LEFT. MY GOODNESS. LISA'S ASKED
FOR FOUR. BUT, THANK YOU SO
MUCH. HAVE A WONDERFUL 4TH OF
JULY WEEKEND. WE'RE NOW
ADJOURNED.